foreign
thank you and with that I'm going to
open the public hearing on Senate Bill
and recognize Senator Carson introduce
her bill
good morning Mr chairman and good
morning honorable members of the House
criminal justice and Safety Committee
for the record my name is Sharon Carson
and I have the pleasure of representing
Senate District 14 comprising of the
towns of Londonderry Hudson and Auburn
and I have for your consideration this
morning Senate Bill 29 which seeks to
repeal the statute relative to police
matrons
ladies and gentlemen it is 2023
and to use the term matron
in discussing our female police officers
is and
Antiquated and quite frankly insulting
and it's time that we do away with this
term and honor the women in blue who are
out there every day serving us and that
is all that this bill does is it removes
the term matron
um we do have
um some women police officers here today
who will will speak with you and the
this bill really came from the New
Hampshire associations of the chiefs of
police
um and again this statute has been in
existence since 1915 and quite frankly
we've come a long way baby and it's time
that this needs to go so Chief I believe
Emily Cobb from the New London Police
Department is here to testify and can
answer any questions that you have so at
this point Mr chairman I will end my
testimony and I hope that your committee
can look favorably on passing this Bill
thank you very much for your time this
morning thank you and I think probably
only three of us get the Virginia Slims
preference I know
laughs
seeing no questions for Senator thank
you thank you
chair recognizes Chief Emily Cobb
good morning
thank you chairman Roy and committee
members my name is Emily Cobb and I
currently serve as the police chief for
the town of New London I'm a lifelong
resident of New Hampshire I began my law
enforcement career over 18 years ago as
a police officer in my hometown of
Claremont then I moved on to the New
London Police Department in 2016 and
I've been serving since Chi as Chief
since March of 2020.
one day not too long ago I was reading
through RSA 105 police officers and
Watchmen when I Came Upon 105.5 police
matrons
and the RSA reads
quote women may be appointed as police
matrons and thereupon shall have within
the limits of the city or town all the
powers conferred by law upon constables
except in relation to the service of
civil process
I had read this RSA years ago long
before I became a police chief and I
remember thinking to myself at the time
that that seems outdated
but despite my thought of it being
outdated I didn't feel at the time that
I was in a position to enact any change
fast forward to my more recent reading
of RSA 105.5 this time as a police chief
I had a conversation later that night
with my husband who was also a police
chief about police matrons and I
mentioned to him I thought it should be
repealed and he encouragingly said to me
you know you can do something about that
now
and he was right so I soon reached out
to Beth Sargent and I'm honored to be
here today testifying before you in
support of this uh bill
um on behalf of myself and the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police
Mr chair and members of this committee
this RSA was enacted over 100 years ago
in 1915 and a lot has happened since
then
over those 100 plus years many many
women have proudly taken the oath
honorably worn the badge and bravely
protected the people of our great state
in recognition of all the women who came
before me and my fellow female law
enforcement colleagues of today I offer
my gratitude to them their families and
their sacrifices
as female law enforcement professionals
we bear many titles in addition to that
which is inscribed on our badge
wife mother daughter sister friend and
more
one title we should not continue to
permit in the codified laws of the State
of New Hampshire however is matron
the Merriam-Webster definition of matron
as it pertains to a police station is a
woman who supervises women or children
that was indeed the role of women in the
Hampshire law enforcement in our history
a role in which they fulfilled a
critical and valuable need in the
protection of people in our society a
role which they should be applauded for
however times have changed and New
Hampshire law enforcement has evolved
I offer to you Mr chair and members of
the committee that women in New
Hampshire law enforcement today are
certainly more than what this outdated
statute provides for
and so on behalf of myself my fellow
female law enforcement colleagues and
the New Hampshire Association of chiefs
of police we are asking that you repeal
105 5 as it is an Antiquated statute
that can be removed from New Hampshire
law we ask that Evo ought to pass on
Senate bill 29. I remain grateful for
your consideration and appreciative of
your time today thank you
thank you Chief
um
just a question I agree with everything
you said but I have a question regarding
that role
um
are there any currently anyone in the
state that you're aware of appointed as
a matron none that we are aware of we
did ask through the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police to all
the Chiefs in the state if there were
any currently serving police matrons and
we did not receive any
responses that there were and the the
historical role would be if a female was
arrested the matron would search and Etc
is that is that correct essentially yes
yes so for departments in the state that
do not have a female police employee how
would they handle that situation much in
the same way that I would search a male
prisoner we are trained at the New
Hampshire Police Academy on how to
appropriately search and process someone
of a different gender and so I suspect
that in a department that doesn't have
female Law Enforcement Officers they
would revert to their training and how
they were taught to search someone again
much the same way I search male
prisoners so the the name
notwithstanding there's no role for this
this position not as far as the New
Hampshire Chiefs are concerned no okay
thank you very much you're welcome
further questions
saying none thank you for your testimony
chief
is there anyone else wishing to
testifying this bill who was not
testified in this bill
seeing none oh hereby close the public
Hearing in HP 29. and the committee will
stand in wreath
um no it's it's noted for tomorrow
uh we'll be in recess till 9 30.
Terry
this time I opened a public hearing on
House Bill 38 excuse me Senate bill 38.
and I recognize
daily for that for that
he is
good morning chairman Ryan members of
the committee my name is Daley frenette
and I am the Senate majority caucus
director I'm here today to introduce
Senate Bill 38 FN on behalf of Senator
Gannon Senator Gannon is currently in
the hospital and he regrets not being
able to be here in person
is signed into law Senate bill 38fn
would improve RSA 594 colon 14 by
amending the procedure for issuing a
summons instead of an arrest this bill
would authorize law enforcement to issue
a summons in lieu of arrest if the
officer has probable cause to believe
the person has committed a misdemeanor
or violation
for example under current law a person
who has failed to renew a dog license
has committed a violation
even though it is only a violation under
RSA 594 colon 14 in its current form
arrest is the only option for law
enforcement
while current law allows a judge to
convert an arrest warrant to a summons
it is unnecessarily required it
unnecessarily requires law enforcement
to file with the court resulting in an
unnecessary use of law enforcement and
judicial resources
the judicial branch discussed this bill
with both the chiefs of police and ACLU
and both indicated their support for the
bill
the Senate Judiciary Committee amended
the bills so the statute would not apply
if a peace officer has probable cause to
believe that a person has committed
abuse violated temporary temporary or
permanent protective order or violated
stalking provisions
the bill was unanimously voted ought to
pass the amendment on the consent
calendar by the Senate
thank you for allowing me to speak today
I will defer any questions to Richard
head from the Department of Justice
because he will be able to answer your
questions more effectively thank you and
please extend the committee's well
wishes to Senator Gannon absolutely well
thank you
chair recognizes attorney head from the
court
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch Ms Daly said we have
spoken with
ACLU police Chiefs and the DV Coalition
regarding this bill all I've signed off
on the on the language and and this is a
bill that we've requested and it's it's
from our end our perspective a resource
issue so we get requests for arrest
warrants on
events that simply should not be an
arrest warrant or the event so for
example as Daley said the
um
there are certain requirements that
trigger an obligation under current law
to seek an arrest warrant
if the event is committed in front of an
officer they can arrest
if under statutory Provisions if there's
a violation of a domestic violence order
or an otherwise a protective order
within a certain number of days a an
arrest can occur without a warrant or if
there's an immediate risk of concealing
or destroying evidence an officer can
arrest without a warrant but otherwise
an arrest warrant is required requires
going to the court and this is for
both misdemeanors and violations
um so you know if you have an unpaid dog
license fee and that gets referred to
law enforcement law enforcement under
current law would have to get an arrest
warrant and then what typically happens
is the judge is going to either convert
that to a summons or what also sometimes
can happen is at the discretion of the
officer that arrest warrant is obtained
but the summons is issued in lieu of the
arrest
simply as a as
based upon the nature of the event that
is given rise to the to the need for an
arrest warrant
um this is uh a discretionary option
available to law enforcement it does not
require summons being issued in in lieu
of
um so it's really you know those
instances where it really does not give
rise to the obligation and and the
record of having received an arrest
warrant
um and having to to go through the
arrest process
um so it is
um from the judicial branches
perspective sort of an unnecessary
filing that comes before the court an
unnecessary use of the of the judicial
resources when these can really be
decisions be that can be made at the law
enforcement level
um so with that I'd be happy to answer
any questions uh that the committee may
have thank you
thank you um so what this would do
is the criminal complaint would issue
upon the writing of the summons versus
the way it was now is the criminal
complaint would issue because the
officer had to arrest the person that's
correct so basically just bypasses that
arrest warrant stage where they have to
petition the court for the arrest
warrant and allows the the or the the
criminal complaint to be issued with the
summons or as a summons
any further um representative salig
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question can you just clarify
if if we pass this what are the
circumstances where like give maybe a
couple of examples of where a warrant
would still be required because I'm I'm
just trying to discern that from the
language and getting caught in my own
head a warrant could be issued in any of
these cases this does not limit the
officer's ability to seek and obtain an
arrest warrant
um this bill is limited in terms of
providing the discretionary option in
only in misdemeanors and violations
um and but it it is
it is in no way a mandate on on Law
Enforcement issue it has a summons but
in and of itself it only applies to
misdemeanors and violations
represent Rhodes
oh sorry representative Catherine
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I guess I have a
concern about that that it's up to the
law enforcement to make the decision and
if there's no guidelines behind that so
and so thank you for for pointing that
out so there are guidelines it's the
same guidelines that one would have for
the arrest warrant so the language is
still has probable cause to believe that
a person has committed and and that
ultimately is the standard by which the
summons would be issued or an arrest
warrant uh would be issued this simply
does it similar to what would happen in
a traffic stop you get a summons instead
of a an arrest warrant ultimately if
there is a defense to that that can be
raised before a judge to say there was
no probable cause for this some for the
summons to be issued so it doesn't it
doesn't take the court out of it it
simply eliminates the arrest that go the
arrest warrant that would be issued to
that that individual where a summons is
a more appropriate
follow up okay I think I think I
understand what you're saying however I
I guess for me if you have a
if it's up to their discretion
let me say this
um
if it's up to their discretion and um
a person decides that the law
enforcement officer decides not to use
this method that's in here and therefore
it has to get a warrant what's the
difference what at what point is that
decision okay or do you are you going to
have documentation for me
um we do have issues
in law enforcement in New Hampshire and
and particularly when it comes to people
of color
and so for me is there going to be any
documentation you know just to make sure
that everybody's getting the same type
of treatment with this law in place
um so thank you for the question I think
I don't
we a couple things actually we are
in in our system working on
being able to extract data about
um individual
um sex ethnicity
personal data that we currently do not
extract out of our system our diversity
and inclusion group is trying to work on
our data so that we can extract more
uh drill down a little bit more in terms
of information that we have in our
system we currently either for arrest or
summons and and to be clear under the
current system you know
arrest warrants can be converted into a
summons it's just done by a judge
instead of of the law enforcement
officer
um so then at the if we are able to
ultimately input data that can can get
issued into reports which we're working
on the answer to the question will be
yes and that is something I think we're
very close to being able to start
implementing it won't be
old data because we don't have that in
our current system but as we move
forward and are collecting more
information and more data into our
system we'll be able to generate more
detailed reports that we currently do
not
thank you
representative janman
thank you Mr chairman
um
as it stands now if a person
they have reasonable uh suspicion I'm
sorry probable cause probable cause
thank you probable cause then a
misdemeanor has occurred they have to go
before a justice of the peace or a
Justice if it did not incur in front of
them yes right 594 10 notwithstanding so
they would go to them and they would
have to swear out a complaint that that
judicial officer would
assignment and make an arrest warrant
that's they would have to request the
arrest warrant that's correct so if we
pass this bill
that would take that third person out of
the I think that's what she was getting
at it takes that third person out of the
equation so it doesn't take that I mean
it doesn't so thank you for the question
it doesn't take the the judge out of the
equation it changes when the judge
becomes involved in the equation so the
judge is always going to be reviewing
that complaint when it becomes before
them and the standard is still the same
so there's there's simply the the
imposition of an arrest warrant may not
happen in that first instance but at the
end of the day the nature and quality of
the decision making of the of the
arresting officer of the the charging
officer still on gets judicial review
if I could just just for the committee
um there seems to be a lot of confusion
um currently a police officer can only
apply for an arrest warrant
there's no choice
now this bill proposes to let the police
officers say this is a dog license
violation or an overdue library book let
me just write a summons to the person it
goes to the court instead of the officer
going to the court in the beginning and
getting an arrest warrant that's all
that this does it gives an option
and and just don't follow up on that you
know much like with with a speeding
ticket speeding summons you know that
happens to happen in front of the
officer but that is
you know still able to be and is
reviewed and and by the by a judge
I think as a follow-up the question I
would have for you is uh you're
releasing the person
on a summons in lieu of arrest and I'm
reading the form that we're proposing
here that the court be using and it says
the form is actually the current form
that's that's not new in this bill okay
I'm familiar with unfortunately but it
says pending appearance as described
here in you shall remain of good
behavior so in lieu of bailing them from
an arrest you're going to be basically
putting the same condition on them under
the the uh
summons how are we keeping track that
they're released on the summons if
they're interacted with by a police
officer at a further date
in in much the same way as as currently
once
in in terms of of the
behavior of the individual if they are
again before law enforcement officer and
the in for in the law enforcement
officers aware they've been issued a
summons and they have this obligation
um you know he would follow essentially
the same course whether whether it's
good or bad it wouldn't
wouldn't change sort of the obligation
on the individual with on our end we
probably need to make sure our forms our
summons forms and our our charging forms
um have that all that language in it
representative Newman
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
I'm a little bit confused about the the
words that have been omitted here just
based on the description that we've had
of what the current status is
and it originally said the law
originally said in any case which it is
lawful for a peace officer
uh to arrest without a warrant
so it seems like there's a you could
arrest without a warrant and you could
do a summons maybe I I just don't
understand it is the important thing
that part of the bill
or is the important thing the part of
the bill down here when it where it puts
in all these references to other other
laws is that is that the important part
or equally important or
so you could straighten that out for me
so thank you for the question and I
appreciate it so under current law
in in the way as you as you noted it
reads in any case in which it is lawful
for a peace officer to arrest without a
warrant
and then it goes on
um
for misdemeanor or violation
under current law this gets triggered so
the ability to only issue a summons
instead of an arrest warrant has to meet
the criteria for when it is otherwise
lawful for an officer to do that and
that standard is laid out in a different
statute
um under RSA 54410 it lays out the
criteria for when an officer can issue a
summons instead of a a a warrant for an
arrest and really under with with the
section that's being amended for is is
the summons form
so
there are essentially three
primary reasons why a undercurrent law
an officer can issue a summons instead
of an arrest warrant one is if the crime
occurs or the violation occurs in front
of the officer then the officer can
issue a summons instead of a an arrest
warrant
second is if it's a domestic violence or
protective order violation if it occurs
within a certain period of time
a uh a summons can be issued instead of
an arrest warrant
um and then and then the third one is
um
uh actually I forgot about the third oh
if if the if the officer has information
probably cause to believe that
um there will be the evidence will be
destroyed if the time is necessary to go
off and seek an arrest warrant
so take my example of the dog license
the dog license is a violation failure
to pay your dog license fee is a
violation it does not occur in front of
the officer so under current law the uh
the the
standard that's that's crossed out where
it says it is lawful for a police
officer to arrest without a warrant it
did not happen in front of the officer
so it is not lawful under current law
for the officer to issue a summons in
lieu of an arrest warrant what this bill
does is says
it strikes that language and says that a
an officer can issue a summons in lieu
of an arrest warrant if they have
probable cause to believe a misdemeanor
or a violation has occurred
so it it really takes out that
in a very sort of low level event
the obligation under current law of an
officer to get an arrest warrant for
that individual who is not paid their
their dog license fee
you have a follow-up
so it it more or less has the same
standards and everything and it just
makes it simpler and more efficient
maybe would that be uh a good estimate
of what it is it is the same standard
probable cause is still required for the
officer to issue the the summons is
simply is it reduces if so for example I
have on occasion not paid my dog license
fee on time if I were to get an arrest
warrant for that I think most people
would be pretty shocked that they're
getting an arrest they're getting
arrested for failure to pay a dog
license fee they would expect something
along lines of a summons and I think
that's really what we're trying to
address in this rather than an officer
coming to the judge the judge then
having to say if that's not what we need
to do we need to issue a summons and
authorize the summons it just reduces
that judicial resource need but does not
eliminate at the end of the day the the
judge's review of the actual complaint
thank you very much for that explanation
represent Stone
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so just to be clear there's still be a
requirement that a probable cause
affidavit is valuable with the court
even though our summons is issued they
would not issue an affidavit it would be
described in the summons what what the
event was and then ultimately when the
judge is reviewing that summons in the
context of the substance of it they
would be determining whether or not
there was probable cause for that
summons to be issued
so it's not an affidavit at the time of
the summons the summons uh lays out the
facts and actually the complaint plays
out the facts sorry
um and that ultimately gets reviewed by
the judge but the but a separate sort of
um uh affidavit like you get with a a
request for a an arrest warrant is it's
just a different document but the the
review is still the same at the end of
the day
thank you
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman
um thank you attorney head I'm just a
little bit confused about the bill
itself as well and I'm wondering if
there's any concrete examples that you
have of this happening where an officer
has to arrest someone for a violation
you know the dog catcher example has
that happened before and
um it it has
um the another one would be
um a kid who takes an ATV out and
trespasses on someone's property
um and
just gets picked up for that
um it's it's along those lines that
we're talking about
representative Muse
thank you for taking my question
um I
I'd appreciate it if you could maybe
walk me through how
this law
doesn't have potential to create
um
a a level of disparity uh between let's
say officers in one community may kind
of get together and decide okay we're
only going to treat this particular type
of crime or violation uh that we're just
going to issue with summons for that or
is in another Community for exactly the
same crime officers could say no I think
we'll do you know we'll have to issue an
arrest warrant I think the guidelines in
the in the bill are pretty clear for
things like stocking violations but
there seems to be an incredible amount
of discretion and I guess in your
opinion are we opening the door to
um
treating people in different communities
in different ways for the same crime
so thank you for the question I think as
a practical matter
some of this may not change anything
because sometimes in a in just been
related to judge king that sometimes the
arrest warrant is obtained
because that's the requirement but a
summons it's ultimately
you know the person is contacted and
they said come down and get your summons
um it is simply in terms of
what why we brought it Forward is it
eliminates sort of the judicial resource
step of getting a an arrest warrant
where uh is simply is clearly not needed
I think
you know in terms of of
law enforcement
you know you you've heard plenty of
testimony from law enforcement that you
know the the issue of repeat offenders
is is a concern for them we're not
talking about that type of situation
we're talking about low-level offenses
where an officer
it simply has no they recognize that the
the
person receiving an arrest warrant in
that circumstance is
is an excessive event for for the nature
of the the crime or violation that has
occurred
um and and I think as a practical matter
it may not change at the end of the day
what that person is receiving where law
enforcement currently may be getting an
arrest warrant
um and it's either getting converted by
a judge to a summons or they're simply
issuing a summons at the time uh instead
of of an arrest
um so as a practical matter I'm not sure
it would change anything I think you
know if there is concern over time that
that there is a disparity occurring we
obviously can be Revisited but in terms
of our experience now it is simply you
know those events where it is
it would be truly shocking for the
individual to receive an arrest warrant
when they would expect to see something
more along the lines of a traffic
violation
a attorney ahead if you could indulge me
for a second
just for so everyone understands
currently the officer doesn't have
there's a lot of questions about officer
discretion if if an officer is referred
a case from the uh from the town says
this person hasn't paid their dog
license in three years the officer has
no choice but to apply for an arrest
warrant at this point is that is that
correct at that point the officer has
probable cause to believe a violation
has occurred same thing that would occur
under this bill so he but he has no
options it's the only way to get that
person to court is an arrest warrant
application is that correct yeah that is
correct so the absolutely under current
law law enforcement has to come to court
seek an arrest warrant
um as a practical matter once they've
obtained that warrant they've complied
and they may issue a summons at that
point but but the arrest warrant is
still required and that arrest warrant
now is on that individuals record in
terms of the court record so the officer
goes to the court for the dog license
issue applies an arrest warrant because
that's what he has to do and the court
at that point can look at it and
probably will look at it and say no you
can have a summons because we're not
arresting people for dog licenses today
what this does is lets the officer
instead of having to go to court
to get an arrest warrant because that's
all he can do is he can write out a
summons to give the person which is what
the judge would have done anyway exactly
thank you and and
um and and at the end of the day
that summons and the complaint that goes
without summons is going to be reviewed
by a judge just now doesn't have to be
done twice
thank you
thank you enough for the questions then
thank you anyone else is there anyone
else listen to testify on this bill who
has not testified on this bill
seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing house uh Senate bill 38.
committee will be in recess for five
minutes
all these um conversations in this bowl
has to do with intimate Partners
stalking
and marital properties
so
um so I was told
she she's a dog
when it had been
at this point I'm going to open the
public hearing on Senate Bill 182 and
the chair recognizes Senator Regina
Bernstein to introduce her bill
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
for hearing Senate Bill 182
um for the record my name is Regina
Birdsall I'm a state senator for
district 19 which encompasses the towns
of Derry Hampstead and Windham
and I am the prime sponsor of Senate
Bill 182 which is the relative to the
definition of way in driving or
operating under the influence of drugs
or liquor
um this bill was a request from the
dairy police chief based on a decision
from the Supreme from a Supreme Court
decision Diana Rutter versus director
New Hampshire Division of Motor Vehicles
which left a hole in the DUI laws with
regard to the definition of way simply
this what this bill does is it extends
the definition way to seven additional
rsas
um 265 clone 71 which is standing I'm
sorry stopping standing or parking
265 colon 79 it includes it in the rules
of the road
265 colon a-2 driving under the
influence of drugs or liquor
265 colon A3 aggravated driving while
intoxicated 265 colon a-4 operator to
submit to testing to determine alcohol
concentration
365 colon a-25 commercial Motor Vehicle
drivers and 265 colon a-31
administrative review and hearing and I
know that I have members of the I
believe the Derry Police Force here to
speak on it as well
thank you any questions for the senator
seeing none thank you thank you
the chair calls Chief Scott Jordan
Jaster
good morning my name is Scott Jordan I
work for the dairy Police Department as
a prosecutor I've been doing this for
about 35 years I was a full-time police
officer before going to law school and I
prosecuted basically that entire time as
a police prosecutor and as a assistant
County attorney Deputy County attorney
and I work for the town of Darius their
supervising prosecutor
the
what happened was last year the New
Hampshire Supreme Court in this case
it's Diana Rutter versus I believe it's
the Department of Motor Vehicles the
Supreme Court
in its ruling
sorry let me just get
part together
in its ruling basically said that
because of the language of 259 125
which is the definition of way in the
state of New Hampshire now there's two
parts to weigh the first part is very
generic and it applies to almost all
motor vehicle offenses
the second part part two is an expanded
definition of way
in an encompassed four rsas and that's
the only four that were listed in it
encompassed DWI
aggravated DWI
it was a parking system for emergency
parking by the Department of
Transportation by the commissioner to
put in certain signage that one is
considered in there and then there's two
265.79 which is reckless operation
so the ones that we're dealing with
primarily is the DW to 2dwis the
aggravated DWI and regular DWI now in
the case of involving Miss Rutter the
Supreme Court ruled that
since the ALS statute
265 at 265-a colon 4 and the other
enumerated ones that we've listed I
believe 21 and 31. are not included
directly in the definition of way like
the DWI statute and they don't apply
so as such in this case a woman who was
arrested for drunk driving in a church
parking lot
did not face the ALS the administrative
license suspension rules
so in other words the obligation to
consent to blood
doesn't apply
the penalties for refusing or testing
over do not apply
so basically what happens is and I
remember when we started making these
arrests in 1991-92 under the ALS
and DWI have been married at the hip for
over 30 years
and now they've been separated
now in this order and I'd have you all
read the last page of this order
it was an invitation by Justice Marconi
Hans mccorny excuse me
who said this is how we can correct it
simply by adding it and the legislature
took this as a Judicial oversight and
they're giving the opportunity to have
it corrected and that's what we're
asking you to do we're not asking for
anything new
we're asking just to be returned back to
the last 30 years of how we've been
doing business and the fact that DWIs
and ALS run hand in hand
and it's basically making this separate
now depending on where you're arrested
what road you're arrested on is it a
private road is it a private parking lot
if so ALS won't apply
and it it's disparaging or not
disparaging but it gives a
um uneven executive very even-handed and
go across the Spectrum when it came to
DWI and ALS
o thank you
um in this case
the defendant was subject to the oui
laws just not the administration section
of it is that correct correct she
appealed the
um
the imposition of the ALS suspension for
testing over
and the Supreme Court ruled that it
should not have been applied to her
so going forward if we're If This Were
to pass well actually presently someone
could be arrested for the oui
um
found guilty
based on the observations of the officer
and they refused the the breath test and
the blood tests
they can't lose their license for that
but they can lose it for the oui is that
correct
correct but if you remember the ALS is
an intermarine intermediate remedy right
it's an immediate remedy in regards to
the DWI if a person is arrested and they
refuse to take a test
in 30 days their driver's license will
be suspended by the Department of Motor
Vehicles now they have a right to have a
hearing and have due process regards to
that but a DWI arrest
it can take a year way we're doing
covert I've got DWIs right now pending
that a three years old Plus
because of the backlog in the court so
you're talking about a drunken driver
who's arrested by the police charged and
if this case had been in place
they could still have their driver's
license with no penalties whatsoever for
three years
and that's what the legislature in
1991-92 was trying to avoid and put in
place
a way of getting these people off the
road and protecting the public
representative pru
so that three-year-old case
the person gets his license suspended in
30 days which is still suspended for
three years because you haven't had a
hearing no sir the ALS has its own
separate and distinct penalties
so if a person refuses to take a test
and this is the first time
they lose their driver's license for a
period of six months
now if they're convicted of the DWI the
DWI sentence would go on top of that
that's a penalty for refusal it's going
to be consecutive
however if they took a test and they're
convicted of the DWI then they're still
going to lose if they tested over 0.08
they're going to lose their license for
six months under the ALS however
that six-month penalty will run
concurrent so at the same time as any
penalty that the Court gives them for a
license suspension and if it's say that
DWI is two years out now and you did the
six months up front then that six months
will be credited towards that any
suspension that the Court gives them
okay thank you you're welcome
representative Bolton
thanks for taking my question
um
I believe the Supreme Court decision
said that they
um don't know and can't speak to the
legislature's intent in structuring the
law in this way
is it do you know what the legislative
intent was I haven't had the opportunity
to look back that far in the rsas yet
and um
is it possible that it was maybe a
fourth amendment consideration
considering that it's private property
I don't believe so no because the I'm
sorry I don't believe so
um the current DWI legislation which
current one provides for that expanded
definition
that makes no sense where they were
plugging in the ALS to be a stopgap
method to get people off the road it
doesn't make any sense they wouldn't
have included that included that and if
you read Heinz Marconi's descent you'll
see that that's exactly what she's
stating in her descent that these it's
implied and the legislature says we're
not going to take it as implied I'm
sorry not the legislature but the the
overall Court we're not going to take it
as implied if it's not written
and it's very in fact or um the court is
only looking at what is written in the
law there's only four statutes so
they're saying we can't interpret this
but I can tell you in practice
that the ALS for the last 30 years has
been married to the DWI and there's
never been a question about it the
police prosecutors as well as defense
attorneys and the Judiciary have always
agreed up until this last case that ALS
and DWI go hand in hand no matter where
that where it is
thanks for letting me ask another
question
um I remember a little bit of what I
read in the um majority opinion on this
case and I remember that they said that
there are situations in which you might
have administrative license suspension
without a DUI and situations in which
you might have a DUI without ALS
can you speak to what kinds of
situations those would be because I
think that was the Court's reasoning in
supporting overturning the conviction
they basically they're saying they're
not married at the hip
well I I don't believe the court said
that
um where there are situations and they
don't talk about them in the in the
order
and the only one that really comes to
mind is the person who tests positive
for drugs because we don't have a level
of drugs so if the person the blood
comes back that the person's under the
influence of drugs
then no Ayla ALS goes into play because
they didn't test over a 0.08
which is only for the alcohol we don't
have levels on drugs and as such there
is no implied consent
penalty that's applied however the still
the ALS rights are read to them like the
fact that refusal is going to be used
against you in a court of law all those
rights are still in play and they're
still given to the person
but that's the only one I know of
um would one of the cases be a junior
operator perhaps where they're not
allowed to have any alcohol in their
system where it would cause an
administrative suspension
for a person under the age of 21 it's a
0.02
if they test above a 0.02 not have to
just smell alcohol in their breath if
they test above a 0.02 then their
driver's license will be suspended for
that six-month period for a first
offense
I represent go ahead
um I'm just trying to parse out kind of
the reasoning of why way would be
different and if I could just give you a
scenario and you tell me if this would
apply so
um I'm home it's the summer it's
beautiful weather we're all barbecuing
in my backyard right
um my son wants to play basketball he's
got a couple of friends who came over
now in order for him to play basketball
I have to back up the car 15 feet so he
can get to the basketball hoop and
things like that well I've had a couple
of drinks because I'm barbecuing at my
house I'm in my own driveway if I back
up that you know 10 to 15 feet or
whatever and I am confronted would that
be a situation where this doesn't apply
now and would apply if we implemented
this law um this wouldn't apply now and
it wouldn't apply if you amend the
statue just like DWI wouldn't apply for
you in your driveway either okay the
amended the extended definition of way
which DWI falls under does not cover
private driveways it's private parking
lots that are designed for the public
other people come in in other words it's
not just designed for the family this is
my private parking lot in my house
that's a driveway and uh DWI there's
nothing in the way statute that would
ever cover that property okay thank you
you're welcome
represent Baldwin one more
last one unless you keep being
interesting
um apartment building complex parking
lot
apartment building complexes are covered
under the statute that is not a driveway
that is open to the public not only are
the tenants allowed there but anyone
visiting the tenants you have uh
children who go out and play in that
area so yes those are covered currently
under the DWI law and they wouldn't be
covered technically under the ALS given
that here uh given rudder
so we would look to put that back under
with the DWI law
representative Newman
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so I'm just a little confused about what
the way the the law is
it says an act it's relative to the
definition of way
in driving under the influence of drugs
and liquor
so but I when I look at the current law
as written it has way in there and I
don't see anything in the bill that has
anything to do with the definition of
way
I just see that the change that is made
in the law
is just to add the three rsas that you
mentioned
so I'm I'm just curious is it the
definition of way or is it just that you
want that this bill intends to
incorporate a the ALS laws
with
I'm not sure what with Waze
the the change that we're looking for is
within the words and phrases and the
definition of way
they Define they expand the definition
of way and it says for the purposes
of these statutes this is going to be
the definition of way
so all we're asking for is there are
currently
one two three four statutes that are in
there
the current definition of way
or the the current definition of way
under section two is the definition for
these statutes
so for DWI aggravated DWI and for
reckless operation and for that parking
statute the expanded definition of way
is applicable to those statutes
and it's always been applicable to ALS
until this court order
all we're asking is that you put that
back inside the definition of way under
two and be applicable to the
administrative license suspension and
that's what those three rsas involve
the ones that are added on to the end
right I understand the ALS but I I just
don't understand there's a definite I
mean there's no other definitions at all
and there's no definitions in here are
there definitions excuse me for the
follow-up
is the definition in the three rsas that
you where exactly is the definition of
way
the definition of way is within the
statute we're looking to amend if you
read past the three rsas it says any
public Highway Street Avenue Road alley
Park parking lot or Parkway any private
way laid out under authority of Statute
ways provided and maintained by public
institutions to which state funds are
appropriated for public use any
privately owned and maintained Way open
for public use any private parking lots
including parking lots and other
out-of-door areas of commercial
establishments which are generally
maintained for the benefit of the public
so that is the definition the expanded
definition of way under section two of
the definition of way
thank you I'll reread this
thank you for your testimony you're
welcome
you want this
I just
the chair calls chief of Becky
could I uh with your permission Mr chair
I'd just like to have uh our prosecutor
stay up here for a few more minutes
um so Mr chair members of the committee
my name is Joe hubecki I'm the immediate
past president of the New Hampshire
Chiefs of police and I'm also the chief
of police in Hollis I speak today and
supported this legislation and I urge
you the committee uh to pass this to
give you some historical perspective in
August of 2022 I received an email from
a concerned Chief so happens to be your
boss about this Statute in some
inconsistencies with the definition of a
way
I think this is an important and
necessary change I won't reiterate and
I'll keep my remarks brief anything uh
what my colleague here has mentioned but
I I do think it's important to reiterate
the fact that within the Supreme Court
ruling
the the final paragraph of the order
says
um that our legislator has sought to
close various loopholes and get tough on
DUI uh by making
um changes to uh DUI Law and I think
that's a important to remember here and
it's appropriate given the fact that
last year alone there were 134 traffic
fatalities in the state of New Hampshire
in between 2009 and 2018 which is the
most recent data I could find provided
by the CDC there were roughly 354
fatalities in New Hampshire contributed
to impaired driving so these changes are
needed and I would urge you to support
this legislation
and I thank you
thank you Mr chairman could you just
repeat
those statistic numbers you just gave I
didn't have my pen ready fast enough no
problem ma'am uh 134 traffic fatalities
in 2022 in New Hampshire that was of
December 30th uh 2022 and then between
2009 and 2018 a 10-year period uh as
provided by the CDC there was 354
fatalities in New Hampshire contributed
to impaired driving so this is important
this is very important
representative Bolden
thanks for taking my question I wanted
to clarify the quote um that you cited
from the Supreme Court ruling was that
from the minority opinion the dissenting
opinion it was yes
thank you for your testimony thank you
Mr chair
is anyone else wishing to test found
this bill was not
seeing no one I'll hereby close the
public hearing on SB 182
committee will be in recess until 10 30.
thank you chairman Roy and honorable
committee members for the record my name
is Senator Deborah alchiller I represent
Senate District 24 which includes the
towns of Exeter Greenland Hampton North
Hampton Hampton Falls rye and stratum
and I'm here to introduce Senate Bill
244 relative to false public alarms in
the beginning of this current school
year CNN published an article about the
Fallout from active shooter hoaxes
beginning with a school in Arkansas and
multiple schools in Florida students
teachers and parents all traumatized by
this experience you have that article
coming around to you
then it was our turn in New Hampshire
less than apprehended will terrorize our
communities and exhaust our resources
that's the purpose of this bill
in which instance can you point to where
this has happened in New Hampshire from
an adult as an adult uh committed a
false report on a high school or School
here in New Hampshire I thank you for
your your question representative
wheeler
um
what I can point to is that there have
been 12
false reports
of active shooters that have cleared out
schools that have traumatized
communities that have traumatized
children who are in those schools and
when those
perpetrators are apprehended for these
false reports they will suffer nothing
more than a misdemeanor violation
and it is the opinion of the New
Hampshire State Senate that that is
inappropriate and that this kind of
terrorizing deserves to be acknowledged
for the seriousness that it is thank you
representative here at Gathering
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I actually have the same concern that
representative wheeler has and I looked
at some of the notes from the Senate and
the question was
um
bad eyesight and the answer was yes
but it's not likely to happen would you
have a problem in some type of amendment
that would um kind of
um
not allow that 15 16 17 year old to be
charged with a felony
[Music]
So currently that is under the judicial
discretion of our County attorneys and
our attorney general
your your mic isn't on
sorry about that
um the the current statute as I read it
already has uh at least one type of
incident that already is a class B
felony if it's called in and that's uh
if somebody calls in a false report of a
Biohazard
uh so there is precedent uh for doing
something like this in our statute
correct indeed there there is precedent
for this
um so a biohazard
um
and the Senate has also added in bomb
threats
um so we have uh we have a more
um we have a heavier penalty on calling
in a Biohazard
than we do in calling in an active
shooter
hoax so
you know this this seeks to acknowledge
the seriousness
of that
follow up please follow up
and part of the reason for separating
incidents like this from incidents for
for example just pulling a fire alarm at
high school and I think we've all been
through been through that but one of the
reasons why you might treat this
differently is because the level of of
police and resource response
um the level of uh fear and the type of
response especially after of all the it
can generate in parents
um calling in a threat of this nature
would appear to
um
just
really kind of put this type of an
offense it really a totally different
level than some of the other things
we're usually talking about is that how
you see it
um that's that's indeed how I see it we
we have required our schools
um
by the change in our culture
to prepare
for an active shooter and the
preparation includes drills and every
time we do that we now know that our
students are you know are traumatized
because they know they know what
happened in Nashville they know what
happened in Parkland they know they're
not unaware they're not unaware at all
little ones are not unaware older
students are not unaware and when a hoax
comes in and sends a community
into panic and parents rushed to the
schools and the state police rushed to
provide Mutual Aid and like in the towns
that I mentioned before
ten towns all on one day responding to
their schools 10 communities sent into
tailspins that's a serious serious
thing to do and it it deserves a a
serious response from our
judicial system in my opinion and in the
Senate's opinion
represent salic
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
my school system was also subject to one
of these um
folks's Terrace hoaxes prior to the
school day beginning because of our
later start time so they were able to
clear it before students arrived
thankfully but um
one of the many impacts you talked about
is the fiscal cost of bringing in all
these resources I'm wondering if you
have
um information
um let me be clear I I support your
promotion but I just I'm curious for
people who might not be able to see past
the the certain elements but to the
fiscal cost of of what it is and if you
have a sense of how much that is in
terms of bringing in all of these
resources
um to a school
um well that would be that would be an
interesting
um collection of of bills
um but if in the p in the M article that
you have which is uh referenced in my
testimony as B and it is from
Seacoast online and it references the
the training that our school Community
engaged in prior to school beginning so
that they were prepared
um
you know anytime uh local municipality
has to send everybody out and call in
for Mutual Aid that's a significant cost
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I appreciate this very much as a
mother of a high schooler who
um I believe times don't take it as
seriously as it should be and it
absolutely should be my question is when
there's something like that that Keane
experienced where it was a tick tock
Trend
um you know and I'm not I'm not saying
I'm not condoning that whatsoever but my
question is if someone shared something
on social media that was something like
that would they still be accountable in
the same way
um so this bill specifically refers to
hoaxes that are called into schools
that then subsequently warrant response
and
all practice policy and precedent right
now shows that
response is as if it were real so
um I can't speak to whether your
municipality would
do an all-out response from a social
media post or they might do an
investigation into that social media
post but when a school
receives a call saying there's a an
active shooter in the building
they have to they have to go into they
have to go into their predetermined
response I I couldn't speak to this bill
doesn't address if somebody saw
something on any kind of social media
platform we're talking about actual
calls that come into the schools
follow up really quickly
um just really quickly so so essentially
at that point what it seems to me like
it's it's dependent on the level of
response so in Keen for example they did
find it uncredible they still went
through the school day my son stayed
home and I was fine with that because he
was scared
um but but there was not there was an
investigation but not uh an all hands on
deck because they did not find it to be
credible because it was Tick Tock so the
the distinguished distinguishing factor
of whether it would be prosecuted in
this way or not is not whether it's a
phone call but it's the level of
response am I clear on that or maybe not
so much
I'm gonna I I'm gonna have to
take a moment and and possibly refer
back to you in or refer back to the
committee in writing I need to
formulate a more articulate response but
um this bill is does not
um
does not address potential
threats that have not occurred
from social media
or potential threats from rumors this is
actual threats actual
reports of an active shoot Act of an
active shooter okay I think so yeah
representative Newman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
you referenced that a class B felony is
three and a half to seven years
um
if something like this were to happen
isn't it isn't it
the outcome may be the judge will
determine whether it's first offense the
the ability of the person thought they
were fully aware of that so the
potential punishment could be much much
less
could even be a misdemeanor or or lower
is that correct thank you for the
question representative Newman
um
as this bill is written it does leave
prosecutorial
um and
um adjudication
within its current
leeway it offers the opportunity
for a judge should they want to or
should it be
appropriate to bring the potential
incarceration of a maximum of seven
years
because that is what we have determined
in New Hampshire to be an appropriate
response to a class B felony
this proposal is to bring this very
traumatizing and terrorizing event into
the umbrella of Class B felonies but it
is not we don't have mandatory
sentencing for class B felonies there's
judicial discretion so indeed you are
correct
follow-up I might not might not have
been clear in this state I believe
that for there to be a mandatory minimum
that mandatory minimum must be written
into the law which it affects that makes
it there are mandatory minimums in this
state I believe I'm
if you want to say anything about that
there's there's a range there's a range
because we have
we have put a range into our
um our penalty phases so Class B
felonies this would be a class B felony
within that range
thank you thank you
representative Muse
um this bill addresses uh one type of a
of a crime that's become more common
called uh called swatting and when it
comes to the uh when it comes to the
level of penalty my understanding is
that other types of swatting incidents
have resulted sometimes in people losing
their lives or being severely injured is
that where you could see uh in a in in
the law that we're talking about now the
bill that we're talking about now is
that a situation where you might see a
judge using some of that discretion when
it comes to maybe going to the farther
end of the spectrum maybe to seven years
or something like that
um well I think you for the question
um but I I can't hypothesize what a
judge may or may not do with that but
your
your assessment of the intensity of
response of these kind of Collins of
active Shooters is correct when we had
it and we thought it was real our team
went down to do that thankfully it
wasn't but the parents racing down Main
Street in Concord that was real
the woman who came and dropped her knees
outside the fence that was real we told
her we were standing there with police
officers and told her in that moment
that it was a fake call and I was so
relieved to tell her but that what she
experienced was real this is real trauma
being under some people and people need
to be held accountable for it and
everyone knows what is happening in our
country so it's not it's not a hoax it's
not a joke this is serious
thank you
thank you Miss Hawkins
Mr holbecki
chief o Becky I apologize
morning again
Madam chair members of the committee my
name is Joe habecki the chief police in
Hollis in the media past president
of the New Hampshire Association a
Chiefs the police I wasn't uh planning
on uh providing testimony but I'm happy
to do so uh the association supports
this bill
um
I asked the question of you all why are
we not doing this
why would you not support this bill
turn your television on open the
newspaper
look on the internet
this is becoming more frequent
in its extremely alarming as apparent to
an 11 year old and as a Public Service
public safety professional
some of the things I heard was
the immense uh taxing of resources to
respond to these incidents
that is true it's very true
as a chief my job is to mitigate risk
it's one of the most important things I
do when you have a large-scale response
I work for a small town so we rely
heavily on Mutual Aid when you have a
large-scale response
um it elevates risk it elevates risk to
everyone
that's what I'm making overtime
that's time and a half of an officer's
hourly wage and it can become quite
costly
additionally it creates a heightened
level of fear
are we just to
allow this to continue without holding
folks accountable
I don't think that's a good option
there needs to be accountability for
people who do this
particularly as a way to capitalize
on the horrific gross acts of violence
that we see in our schools and in other
places of gathering whether they be
places of worship
shopping malls
supermarkets Etc
be happy to take any questions you or
try and answer any questions you have
thank you chief chief are you aware of
any arrests made for this crime in this
state in the last year
for what you folks have referred to as
swatting type calls uh I'm not Mr chair
I can certainly look into that and
report back to the committee yeah I'm
interested in knowing um
have we have we have do we have cases
where we wished we could have charged a
felony but couldn't because the law sure
yeah I know these becoming they're
oftentimes very complex to investigate
because folks will use you know spoofing
apps and things like that this is such a
problem I'll put it in this context that
the FBI actually has a specific training
um for Public Safety agencies not just
police but also fire
um EMS because oftentimes those folks
are taxed to respond to these types of
calls they had actually organize a
training
for municipalities so they could be more
uniform and standardized in their
approach to these types of calls so it's
getting out of hand
that that raises another question if I
may
um are you aware if there's a federal uh
crime for this because it is used in
telephonic so it would fall under the
federal law if if they still choose and
I'm sure there probably are federal
statutes that do apply to this
um I will say you know I find it kind of
a lot that we have in statute 6443 we
have language relative to
chemical spills
we have felony level offenses for folks
that tamper with fire alarms
but we're arguing over the merits of
making a you know felony level offense
for folks that call in an active shooter
just makes no sense to me I would I
would say that we're not arguing I think
that we're just trying to make sure
I'm passionate about this issue so I
understand
um representative janburn
Jacob thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question thank you sir
so
I'm looking to
when fishing game gets a call
that somebody's lost in the woods and
they have to respond and they respond
with many people to go and do a search
party
and that person didn't have the hike
safe card or didn't have a hunting or
fishing license they're usually charged
to reimburse the department for that
service sure
um
with this type of crime
do you think that it would be
appropriate
in addition to the felony to also charge
that person for the responding agency's
expenses
it's a valid question I'm not sure I can
give you a good answer I know the courts
the courts would probably have issue
with it I mean we've
in various instances where people have
committed violations or crimes I can
think of when I was a member of the SWAT
team where we've tried to to Bill folks
for over time
um for the folks that were responding to
the call and the courts can go either
way judges are typically very cautious
to
mandate restitution like that for
certain cases so I guess my answer to
you is I don't know how to answer it's a
difficult question to answer
in theory I think it's a good idea but I
don't I don't know how the courts would
perceive that and and see that
representative Murray
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I was looking forward
um is it not true that sometimes these
calls can be made by potential Shooters
to almost see like what the response is
like and so they can make plans for
their
um you know crime in the future so if we
passed a bill like this it potentially
could stop a shooting before it even
happened as the person would be arrested
and charged with a felony before they
even had the chance to carry something
like that out
valid argument valid point and that's
true oftentimes
you know folks will test response
um and that's not a new phenomenon that
done that with things such as Bank alarm
response and such for many many years so
it's a valid point and I would agree
with your questions slash statement
Representatives say like
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um I've been doing some work recently
related to PTSD and First Responders and
um
um in addition to all of the PTSD that
this would cause teachers and students
and parents
um I'm curious if you could speak to how
responding to these calls might trigger
PTSD in First Responders and
for
people who might be more focused purely
on fiscal aspects rather than on
practical and safety ones what the
financial impact of having
that occur might be
so in my opinion these could be you know
what they refer to as triggering events
for folks that maybe have existing pts
conditions
certainly it elevates
um
you know an officer is hyper vigilance
when you're responding to these calls
whether or not they're legitimate or not
I don't know if any of you have had the
opportunity to watch the video from
from Nashville
if you haven't please do listen to the
officer's breath
that will indicate to you the stress
placed on the human body when you
respond to these critical incidents
whether they're legitimate or not
so I am very concerned about the
increases as it relates to pts and
having it be a triggering event
as you said there are costs not just
in terms of resources per se but the
burden placed on
people there's liability issues work
workers compensation
it's hard to quantify
the dollar amount fiscally that
uh
with the impact as it relates to these
types of calls and these types of ins
instances
I'm curious if the Chiefs Association
has seen officers who are leaving the
force because of this type of threat
I'm sure there's I'm sure there's some I
mean these are tough times for law
enforcement and
um I think we're losing a lot of folks
um
I saw a recent statistic where I think
Statewide we're down roughly 300
officers or more
um from what was
a more robust uh I guess population of
officers in the state you know 10 years
ago
there's a number of police officers
leaving in the profession whether it be
by way or retirement or just simply
resigning
and I think
heightened stress
and the threat to safety is one of many
factors leading to that
thank you
thank you chief for your testimony thank
you Mr chair
at this point no one else willing to
testify wants to testify
going once going twice closed
at this point I am going to open the
public hearing on Senate Bill 245
and the chair recognizes
daily renette again
good morning chairman Roy and members of
the committee hello again
my name is Daley frenette and I am the
Senate majority caucus director I'm here
today to introduce Senate Bill 245 on
behalf of senator rashardi
Senator shorty was asked to sponsor this
legislation by the New Hampshire lodging
and Restaurant Association
the bill is really a housekeeping Bill
to update the law to better reflect the
reality of the industry with modern
technology
RSA 353 colon 3 requires a lodging
establishment to keep a record of the
guests that have booked rooms and to
make that record available to public
safety personnel if necessary
the statute was enacted in 1927 well
before the Advent of computers now that
this information can be kept
electronically it's about time that we
update the law
there really is no need for a hotel to
keep a book or card system to have the
guest sign in
SB 245 removes the Antiquated reference
to book or card system and simply
requires the hotel to keep a record of
the guests
Senator rashardi has drafted Amendment
language which was sent to the committee
a few days ago Sarah shorty hopes that a
member of this committee will be willing
to have this language drafted in their
name so that the committee can consider
it as a committee Amendment the
amendment language addresses an issue
that arose in the Senate Judiciary
Committee at the last minute the
committee Amendment amended the bill to
keep the language in the law about the
guests providing their legal name or the
name by which the guest is commonly
known
when it did so it reinserted the word
sign
with remotes with remote check-in and
checkout there is sometimes no need for
the guest to sign in this amendment
language removes the requirement to sign
in and simply requires the hotel to keep
a record of the guest's legal name or by
which the guest is commonly known
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak today I will defer
any questions to Henry vayu in the New
Hampshire restaurant and Lodging
Association thank you very much
thank you
um
Roy schweiker
at this point the chair recognizes Henry
below
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Henry vayu and I'm here on behalf of the
New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association
and I have to say I think this is the
first time that I've testified before
this committee uh with the logic and
Restaurant Association I live up in the
Commerce Committee or in the labor
committee so I don't think I've ever
been here for the lodging Restaurant
Association but uh it's a pleasure to be
here
um
as was just explained this is really a
housekeeping bill
um it's not intended to change any
policy
the statute right now
RSA 353 colon 3 requires the hotel
basically to keep a record of the guests
and if Public Safety uh suspect there's
a suspect there that they could come and
check the record of the guests and
confirm whether or not the individual is
there
we don't intend to change any of that
what we simply want to do is update the
language in the statute as it was
mentioned it was an act of 1927 that
speaks to the hotel keeping a card
system and a book for the guests to sign
in I mean that's so Antiquated the
industry now as you know it's all online
you can check in remotely
sell
we've crafted the language so that it
basically says look you just got to keep
a record of the guest and keep it open
to inspection by Public Safety when the
Senate was getting it out of the
committee they had the hearing the
hearing was done
we left the room they finished a few
more hearings and at the end of their
hearings they said we can get this bill
out really quickly one of the Senators
wanted to reinsert the language that is
in the current statute that says you
keep their legal name or the name by
which they are commonly known by they
wanted to put that back into the bill
and they did but they also put the words
that are in the statute that say they
signed their legal name which we want to
get away from that that was the whole
intent of the bill so the amendment that
was presented that hopefully you have
before you takes the reference to
signing out and it basically just leaves
it as we wanted to which is just keep
the record of the guest and keep it open
to inspection that's it it's a simple
build
thank you
um just one question how when it's all
computerized if an officer comes in and
says I'd like to see the list for today
how how would the hotel go about showing
them that like in the book they could
just flip to today's page right
um
let me can I have Mike Summers he's the
uh CEO of the uh organization
uh sorry uh so my name is Mike Summers
I'm the president CEO of New Hampshire
lodging and Restaurant Association so
the way the industry works these days is
everything is digitized so if a law
enforcement officer were to come to the
hotel and want to see the records they
would just take them into the office or
behind the front desk and they would
give them the computer screen and just
show them okay who do you want to who
are we looking for so it would all be
ultimately be digitized
so if they for example wanted to see
today's everyone who checked in today
they'd be able to just call that up on
oh absolutely yes
a lot of these hotels they can do it
remotely from you know their corporate
headquarters they can see how many
guests checked in who the guests are Etc
so all that information is available it
would just be a case of them going
behind the desk and giving a monitor to
look at and they could go through the
records thank you
representative Murphy
and thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I just have a
question about
um the um listing of the guest names I'm
assuming that's the guest who booked the
room but not anybody who might be
staying with them like if I booked it my
own name my husband could be a guest so
you don't really have a full description
of who's in every room just the person
that booked it correct and that's been
the historical standard yes okay thank
you
representative scitec
if this is to be used by law enforcement
I think I might suggest words like this
and I'd ask what you might think uh such
a record uh shut um
the legal name of each uh guest
and the name by which the guest is
commonly known if different
or no and
and
that the name that's commonly used if it
is different than the legal name because
you know I could come in and say I'm
sure and I don't tell you what I well
and then frankly I think that uh that's
a a technicality that the committee
could certainly address I think the
intent for us is to update
what the statute because technically
most hotels today are in violation of
the current statute because currently
they're supposed to keep a book and card
system nobody does it's just
exorbitantly expensive and time
consuming and there are also many of
them are not requiring anybody to sign
anything when they check in they're just
checking an ID so ultimately the
language that you feel more comfortable
with I think we're fine with just so
long as we're maintaining those two
changes because that just updates to
what the industry practice is today if
that makes sense
but I think to your point that may be
more grammatically correct as you
describe it
or
either their legal name or the name by
which they're common
thank you and thank you both for your
testimony uh sir if you could fill out a
pink card just so we have you for the
records
at this point the chair recognizes Roy
schweiker
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm Roy schweiger from Concord
and
I agree with the fact that this thing
about the card system is Obsolete and
needs to be changed
but I feel that this whole thing is
Obsolete and needs more changes instead
of catering to the wishes of one senator
I mean I understand you know the old
days the sheriff would wander into the
thing and see who the strangers in town
are and look at the list of guests
and
I don't think that's appropriate anymore
my recollection is there was a certain
bill that the same committee acted on
which had to do with unjust criminal
prosecution HB 89 where some
operator of a camp refused even with a
warrant to give the names of the guests
there and he was convicted and this
Committee just essentially vacated that
conviction this was an unjust
prosecution he was entitled to not give
out the names of the people that
attended his camp
and I think the same thing could be true
with Hotel records why does the police
have a
ability to just wander in and ask who's
staying at the hotel I would say it
might be more correct to do what hotels
do now if you call up and say is John
Smith staying at the hotel they will
admit if he is and they'll connect you
to his room but they won't tell you
where his room is it's up to John Smith
to decide if he wants to uh
admit this person that wants to talk to
him so I think we need to delete that
whole sentence regarding the showing the
thing to the police because I don't
think it's appropriate if they need to
know the list of everybody in the hotel
let him go get a warrant and even then
apparently this committee feels that
even with a warrant it may not be
desirable for the hotel to give out the
list of people so I would say that whole
business about showing the register to
the police officers needs to be removed
and the second thing that essentially is
taken care of maybe with this amendment
about signing the register that once
again the current bill or the current
statute says that every member who's
staying there needs to sign it once
again I would say this is something that
is not enforced either not just
assigning it but like someone said if
one person reserves the room you know
you may not know who else is staying
there
and this bill if it is implemented even
minor children would have to you know
show up and have the name listed even if
they don't have to physically sign
something I think that you know once
again
maybe you want the hotel owner to know
the name of every person including kids
and whatever who's staying there but I'm
not sure that that's true or something
they probably aren't doing today so this
is in effect if you pass it as written
your
should we say saying that the current
statute is correct and they should be
keeping those detailed records and since
presumably they'll now be expected to
follow it now to remove the cards then
they'll be expected to follow it in
terms of the names of everyone who's
there and you know I'm not sure that's
appropriate you know maybe it is but
certainly I think this business of any
police officer walking in and saying I
want to know everyone was staying here
that's you know kind of not in keeping
with what we do elsewhere
I mean once again you read about the
airbnbs they have random people staying
there and causing all sorts of trouble
well they're not affected by this they
can still have you know 10 people show
up and live there because they're not a
place with two or more rooms
so they're exempt from this whereas the
hotels they don't have that problem will
have to follow it so I think that's
inappropriate thank you
thank you and those are good points
committee will take those under
advisement
representative Newman
thank you Mr chair I just have one
question you you referenced a bill that
was in front of this committee could you
do that just give me that number again
HP 89 relative to posthumous
exonerations and annulments
thank you
is there any further anyone else wishing
to testifying this bill who has not done
so
there'd be none I hereby close public
hearing
[Music]
committee being recessed for two minutes
this point of open a public hearing on
Senate Bill 245. no excuse me
Senate bill 81.
and I recognize
Jenny Oregon
good morning chairman Roy members of the
committee for the record my name is
Jenny Horgan I am the Senate minority
policy director and I'm here introducing
Senate Bill 81 on behalf of Senator
Apprentice she has unfortunately has
another bill scheduled at the same time
across the hall so Senate Bill 81 sets a
level for alcohol ignition interlock
devices at 0.020 and was filed at the
request of the Department of Safety and
Joe Carr New Hampshire is an ignition
interlock program requires that any
person whose license has been revoked or
suspended for an aggravated DWI or
convicted of a second or subsequent DWI
to install ignition interlock device in
any vehicle registered or used by that
person for 12 to 24 months the device
prevents the vehicle from starting
unless the person provides a breast
sample with a concentration of alcohol
that is below that preset level
again this legislation was filed at the
request of gel Carr who worked with
rules to address the installation of the
devices during the summer of 2022 so
thank you for your time and
consideration as soon as the senator is
finished testifying across the hall
she's going to race right over here
answer any questions that you have but
we will note that director marasco from
dos is in the audience and does plan to
testify he would be best suited to
answer any technical questions
and that concludes my testimony thank
you very much thank you for coming
this
chair recognizes John Bailey Jen Bailey
excuse me
are you Mr marasco you'll be testifying
together okay
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee uh thank you for allowing us
the opportunity to testify before you
this morning my name is John marasco I'm
the director of The Division of Motor
Vehicles and I'm here with Jennifer
Bailey who is the administrator who
oversees financial responsibility at the
DMV I would like to thank Senator
Prentice for sponsoring this bill as was
testified to jail Cara recommended that
this bill will be put forth and
basically what it allows for sir is it
allows for the DMV rule set with a set
point a .020 to align with what we're
trying to add here to the RSA the the
set point of .020 is a Nitsa national
highway traffic safety administration
set point or preset standard which means
when somebody blows into that device at
that .020 threshold the vehicle will not
start it should be noted that the actual
violation which is in the statute
currently anything that is greater than
a .025 will register as a violation so
some of the conversation that occurred
before jailcar was
the DMV rule set has a 0.020 but that's
less than the .025 violation we're
trying to have both documents have the
same information the benefit of
migrating to the point zero two zero is
uh one it meets the Nitza standard two
it aligns with the DMV rule set and
three currently right now for those that
would be on the program that are under
the age of 21 their threshold for a DWI
with being .020 if we keep it in the RSA
that it just stays at a point zero two
five or greater you could run the risk
of a juvenile that's on the program
blowing a 0.020 and actually legally
driving the car we don't want that so
adding this to the RSA captures that as
well so it's a really good addition to
the RSA and we fully support it
administrator Bailey oversees the
program so if you have any specific
questions I know Jen is happy to answer
them for you
um just out of curiosity why is it .020
not just point zero is that something
that's just not technically feasible
does everyone have a certain amount of
alcohol
that's a great question my understanding
on that sir is that it's a it's an
industry standard most of the devices
although they can be recalibrated my
understanding is that the .020 set point
not only is what Nitsa recommends but I
think they recommend that because the
industry that's the standard that
they're using as well
represent wheeler I have some curiosity
too thank you Mr chairman
just really what how long have these
devices been in use how long have we
been using the uh the ignition
interlocked preset device that's a great
question I have the literature on it
Jen's working with it every day so if
you want want to take that jump
good morning everyone thank you for
having us
um so great question we have been using
interlock devices since about 2012.
um we have recently expanded that at any
given time right now we have about 1300
devices actively being used by residents
of New Hampshire so we had looked to
expand the rules to meet certain
guidelines and this is one of those
things that we did with emergency rule
making and that's when gel car
recommended that we match our law with
that
oh
I missed you said 1300 devices in use
right now yeah thank you
so you know further questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
thank you
is anyone else here wishes to test found
this bill was not done so
you know when I hear if I close the
public hearing and we will be in recess
until 1pm
so
decomposure structural damage to the
home from the decomposing of the body
biological risks from toxic fumes
emitted from the decomposed Financial
loss includes monies spent on hazardous
cleaning crews repayment of Maryland's
pension checks that Craig continued to
benefit from Over the period of her
concealed death and the loss of our
family's Real Estate Value in her home
and um
and sentimental artifacts these are just
a few examples from my personal
experience of this situation the
financial cost emotional emotional toll
and time spent by law enforcement on
this case could have been avoided if
officials were notified of her death as
soon as possible and able to handle it
properly
if caretakers family members or both are
unable to report a death we need to ask
why
it is my belief that there is no
altruistic reason to conceal a person's
death and that more Sinister reasons lay
beyond the actions of hiding it as
members of society it is our duty to the
deceased to protect and honor them just
as we would the living
this is something I wish I had the
opportunity to do immediately upon the
death of my grandmother
she was not just my grandmother she was
also my best friend it was very very it
continues to be very hard I want to
thank you for your time and your
consideration of your support of this
bill and in closing I ask that if given
the opportunity
humbly we could name the bill or law
after her Maryland
thank you for your time
does anybody have any questions for me
or
anything
representative Boldman
thanks for questioning I'm sorry about
everything that happened
um have you been able to obtain any
restitution from Craig
um currently I have sought legal counsel
and I'm working with my lawyer and the
trustee of Maryland's estate to
try to handle this situation
um
unfortunately because there's not laws
in place that say what he did was a
crime
um
there's it's been quite a battle
of course yeah
um just quickly was was did he also take
Social Security checks that we're going
to her so
so the trustee which was
which was so her
New York state school system and then
also Social Security and everything that
had been checked cashed was paid back by
that or taken care of by the trustee
um and so there is a little Nuance of
did Craig commit a crime financially
because he was still benefiting from her
monthly income that was coming in
um because he is a beneficiary of her
estate in the long run that is arguably
not
a big issue I guess for you know lack of
okay thank you very much yeah I think I
think we have everything we need thank
you very much I appreciate it yeah
and the chair recognizes Jenny Duvall
good afternoon thank you my name is
Jenny Duval I'm the chief medical
examiner and
um first let me say that I fully support
this bill as amended in the in the
document as we're passing around the my
only uh concern is where the amendment
is is um is placed in the statute
um by placing it under the office of the
chief medical examiner statute statute
611 you are restricting the amendment to
Medical legal deaths and medical legal
deaths are not all deaths in in the
state they are deaths that fall under
the statute which is 611 b11 there are
26 different scenarios or circumstances
surrounding a death that mandate
reporting it to the medical examiner
but most deaths do not fall under those
scenarios so if you want to capture all
deaths that occur and say all deaths
must be reported then it can't be in my
statute and it can't reference medical
legal cases
and that's why I think this amendment
um fits better under under
the 644 colon 7 which is the abuse of a
corpse statute so that refers to any
deceased person whose death occurred
under any circumstances
so I just think it fits better in that
statute my other concern is that by by
placing it under 611 the medical
examiner statute there could be
unintended consequences to that would
adversely affect our ability to
investigate deaths
so
that's all thank you Doctor
um did you raise these concerns to the
Senate while this was over there or is
this something that came up late in the
game
um I I guess I wasn't aware at the time
that it was it was going through the
Senate
um we did raise some concerns then and I
believe the police testified at that
hearing
um but I'm not sure it was made clear
that what all of my concerns were
representative Rhodes you have a
question
dude thank you Mr chairman
I'm not sure if this is already the law
or if this is verbiage for a new law but
my question that I have is where it says
finds remains which are thought to be
thought to be human
is that is is this what they're trying
to make be a law because my only
question is if I was walking along I I
can assure you that I do not have the
ability to try to decipher what may be
human remains or or like animal
so I'm not
right I would think it should just be
reported
right so the the proposed amendment the
Amendment to the amendment
um is uh is re refers to reporting
failure to report the death of a person
um so I think you know we're all
thinking of
and not skeletal remains or a single
bone but we're thinking of a person who
died and I think that the thought behind
this bill is referring to a person who
dies outside of a health care facility
so someone who dies in a home
um where someone who shares at home is
not reporting the debt sure
so the
the 611 B12 would remain as is minus the
the additions that were proposed is that
correct that that would be my wish yes
okay thank you
from representative scitec
the proposed amendment says a person is
guilty of a misdemeanor
uh
is that what person is responsible for
how do you
is the person has to be responsible for
the care of this person and or if I'm if
I'm hiking in the White Mountains and I
see a remains am I required to am I that
person I
I I think person needs
the amendment has a problem in my view
with the person having a responsibility
with over that person not it
yes I think you could certainly tweak
the amendment I mean right off the bat
the title of the amendment needs to be
corrected because it still refers to a
medical legal death
um and that's part of the problem
um you can certainly tweak this
amendment and
make it more of of the responsible
person
although maybe it should apply to anyone
who's aware that there isn't a decedent
and they're not reporting it probably
should apply to everyone
and that maybe accomplished just by
saying whoever becomes aware of a death
and it fails to report it something like
that okay I think we got it
further questions representative Boldman
um thanks for taking my question could
you define medical legal and maybe give
us some examples of what's in
611-b colon 11. yes so uh as I said and
then to give the context of like why
this isn't where this law should be
understood so 6 11b 11 there are 26
they're lettered a to X and they
describe certain circumstances that
mandate reporting to my office
and they are things like
deaths where there's some criminal
activity involved
any suicide any accident any homicide
um any traffic related death any firearm
related deaths any uh death that's a
public health threat or potentially a
public health threat
um any uh poisoning death which would
include all of the overdoses that we're
seeing so it's it's targeted to
non-natural Deaths so not deaths from
natural disease it's targeting
non-natural deaths or potentially
natural deaths but in a young healthy
person where death is not expected and
where the death may not be natural or or
maybe a public health threat so that's
the the idea behind the statute and it's
a good statute but it would not include
your grandmother you know it would not
include someone who has medical problems
their death is not unexpected
um persons who who die in their sleep
they wouldn't necessarily have to be
reported to my office unless they're not
being followed by a physician or another
provider who could certify their death
thank you so in your proposed amendment
you're not referencing 611-b colon 11 at
all and
um I'm assuming that that's because
um this paragraph 611 Dash B colon 12 is
just a whole other unrelated thing to
their situation and so we don't need to
if we want to amend this we don't need
to take any of the wording
from the bill at all we can strike out
the basically dump the bill as is write
something new in a new section that
captures the intent that yeah I think as
long as you leave 611 out of it
then we should all be fine
representative
sorry thank you very much for taking my
question I'm I'm wondering
whether it makes sense
in some way to have both parts of this
where
um it would be a misdemeanor both to
report a natural death in as in the case
of of your grandmother and I'm very
sorry for your loss but also
the med sorry medical legal I'm sorry
it's an awkward phrase for my mouth
um death that you know essentially and I
recognize that yours reference your
immense proposed amendment references
any death but I'm wondering if we need
to be more specific for any reason just
trying to understand the legalities of
it
is there already a penalty for failing
to comply with uh 611 uh it there is it
says mandatory reporting but there's no
penalty referenced so
yeah I mean maybe maybe they should both
be amended so that there's a penalty
that exists in both
but I still think you want to capture
more than just medical legal cases with
this particular bill got it
see enough further questions thank you
very much
is there anyone else wishing to testify
did you want to add I saw you yeah sure
by all means
if there is a good point
better under
44-7 and changing the
concealing a dead body misdemeanor to a
felony and then adding the mandatory
reporting rule which would Encompass all
deaths and not put anybody in the
medical profession at risk in any way
kind of sounds like the best
um so that's just the comment I wanted
to make okay thank you
is there anyone else wishing to testify
there'd be none I hereby close public
hearing and we'll be in recess until 1
30.
why did I give so much time and it
sounded like it was going to be more
foreign
at this point I'm open in a public
hearing on Senate Bill 209
and I recognize
Senator Becky Whitley introducer bill
all right thank you Mr chair
it's good to see everyone good afternoon
members of the committee for the record
my name is Becky Whitley I'm honored to
represent Senate District 15 which
includes the wonderful communities of
Beau Concord Penacook and Hopkinton
today I'm proud to introduce Senate Bill
209 a bill ensuring menstrual equity in
all of our New Hampshire Correctional
settings
so I understand that this committee is
pretty familiar with this topic
um and I'm grateful to bring for the
Senate version and in my opinion this
bill supports basic human dignity for
women in our County jails our state
prisons and our juvenile correction
facilities this bill acknowledges that
For Those Behind Bars there are some
unnecessary hurdles to coping with
menstruation and managing periods in a
healthy and hygienic way so I'm really
grateful that this bill was the
culmination of work with Advocates with
the um the commissioner from the
Department of Corrections and this bill
was designed to align actually with an
existing policy that the Department of
Corrections already has that works to
ensure the safety of residents and staff
will also ensuring menstrual Equity we
also consulted with the county
superintendents and got their input on
language and I want to thank everyone
who was involved in their partnership
for this work
I think this bill is really important
and the subject is really important
because menstruation is natural it's a
natural monthly occurrence experienced
by half the population for much of their
lives and it should not be treated
differently than any other basic bodily
function menstruation is not something
to be ashamed of however there is so
much stigma stigma and silence around
the topic
menstrual products like tampons and pads
are vital for the health well-being and
full participation of women and girls
inadequate menstrual support has often
been associated with both health and
psychosocial issues particularly among
our low-income residents
lack of access to menstrual products has
all can also take a severe emotional
toll especially if residents are too
embarrassed to take part in daily life
within the prison or facility
incarcerated people are in the custody
of the state and of course rely entirely
on prison or jail staff to meet their
medical and hygiene needs including the
provision of menstrual products the
ability to manage menstruation should
not be a bonus a reward an entitlement
or a favor to be begged or bargained for
and that's where this bill comes in
this bill takes away that power Dynamic
and provides for the provision of the
same basic amount of Mentor products for
all residents there's also some
flexibility built in depending on an
individual's unique needs those who
menstrate on the panel may know full
well that periods can be unpredictable
and that not all people menstruate in
the same way some people have light
flows for a few days while others have a
heavier flow for a full week
I want to point out that the cost of
menstrual products is really negligible
when compared to the cost of actually
running the facilities and the
government already pays for other
necessities like toilet paper we don't
charge for toilet paper so we shouldn't
be charging for menstrual products
this bill I think at its core highlights
that it's a core human need even and
most especially for people in custody
and should be treated as such I'm happy
to take any questions and I respectfully
ask for the committee's support of this
bill I will note that this Bill had
unanimous support both in the senate
committee and on the senate floor it was
amended at the request of a number of
folks including our commissioner to
include our juvenile correction
facilities of which of course we have
girls
um so that's the biggest Amendment and I
think there's a few differences that I'm
happy to discuss with the house version
if that would if that makes a lot of
sense so
um
there is a a line in the house version
that talks about the provision of
underwear
um and I certainly would be happy to add
that to the Senate version as well I
think that was a great Amendment
um it's just not something that we we
thought to include in ours so I think
certainly I would would be open to that
um I think in ours like I said in the
Senate version we do include Juvenile
Detention facilities I think that's an
important thing we also actually Define
what an adequate amount of menstrual
products is we say that everyone
everyone gets 20 right and then of
course there's flexibility from there if
I need more
so I think naming that is really
important because again if you name the
number then you're taking away that
bargaining power Dynamic so I think
folks thought that naming that number
and having that number in there was an
important Baseline um and that is
aligned with what the commissioner
already uses in her facilities and I
think she can speak to the importance of
of naming and why that number was
arrived at
um
so I think those are the major
differences
um there's some you know minor language
issues that I'm happy to address we do
Define menstrual hygiene products a
little differently and that was
um very intentional because I think
there are certain menstrual products
like cups
um that perhaps may not be appropriate
for Correctional settings and I thought
that was fine and so that's why we were
very particular in how we named witch
meds for products we are talking about
here so I will stop there I'm happy to
take any questions and defer you know
more technical questions to the able
folks behind me
thank you Senator um yeah the we we
spent an amazing amount of time on this
and delved into it pretty deeply so we
appreciate the Senate doing the same
thing
and we'll definitely going to um
compare these two and see which one is
better for the the people that it
protects any questions from the
committee members
I fear everyone here has had their fill
of this talk hey you guys are letting me
off easy yeah thank you very much for
your time thank you thank you I
appreciate it
what do you need
the chair recognizes Tony scolabrini
School of brain
scholumber
that's pretty good skull and Brady
scullingbury thank you Mr chair
my name is Anthony skull and Brady I'm a
lawyer in Nashua I've been a lawyer for
about 20 years some of the cases that
I've taken in my career involve people
that are incarcerated involved females
that are incarcerated and on occasion I
have uh sought compensation for people
who are injured while in uh incarcerated
some of the things that that some of the
changes that were made between the
Senate bill and the house bill I think
are really good there's one change that
I want to highlight in particular that I
think is probably not the best approach
and the fir the that changes eliminating
the number of menstrual hygiene products
per individual by setting it at a
reasonable number as opposed to an
actual number it it invites litigation
that would be deleterious to the to the
County Corrections facilities and to the
State Prison I would note though that
I've never had a complaint about this in
any number of years as a lawyer out of
the state prison and it's always been
out of County facilities
by putting a minimum number there it
ensures not only that people get some
and have them when they need them and
maybe could even ration them themselves
but it also eliminates this fuzziness
that could invite litigation I would
also note that this kind of litigation
would be especially tempting because it
would only apply to women so there would
be Not only would there be an issue
related to a 42 USC 1983 which is the
federal statute that allows people to
hold State officials uh
accountable for violations of their
federal constitutional rights but
because it would only affect women it
also have some equal protection
components and so I would urge the
original number to be restored and that
way there is not this essentially uh red
flag for litigation
I'm happy to answer any questions I hope
that I was short and clear
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
and the chair recognizes Devin Quinn
good afternoon chair and members of the
committee my name is Devin Quinn I'm the
policy director for the New Hampshire
women's Foundation we invest in
opportunity and equality for the women
and girls of New Hampshire through
research advocacy
and Grant making
um
I have passed around two documents
I know that this committee is very
familiar with this issue is very
knowledgeable about this issue it's
taken a lot of time
and has a lot of empathy for this issue
so I don't I will let um some of Ophelia
Burnett's testimony speak for itself if
you want to take a look at that Ophelia
could not be here today but she has has
been a wonderful Advocate on this issue
and presents a lot of experiences of
individuals who experience this issue so
I just wanted to make sure that was in
the record you had that with your time I
wanted to just focus on the differences
between the house bill and the Senate
bill just to kind of get down to what's
actually different about them since I
know this is an issue you all support
um the of so in the top here we have a
little
um spreadsheet a little chart of What's
um different about the House and Senate
bills mostly um the rest is the same
um all all of these three things that
are different are really great and I
think should probably be adopted into a
final bill
uh the house bill includes underwear and
the Senate bill doesn't and I know
that's something that this committee
really did great work in adding so I
would recommend that you consider adding
new underwear to the Senate version of
this bill based on that work you did the
only thing I might say is that I know
the subcommittee when I watched that it
you had wanted to do new underwear but
then in the language it came out as in
new condition so I don't know if that
could be read as um
if it was sanitize a new condition
that's a question I have so just
wondering if you wanted it to say new or
new condition
the Senate Bill includes
um both of them include both bills
include
jails and the prison but the Senate Bill
also includes Youth detention facilities
the student Youth Center or whatever
would be applicable in that RSA section
so I would recommend you consider adding
youth facilities as well because we know
that people menstruate in Youth Services
as well
um the final difference and which has
been brought up a few times is um really
defining adequacy as a number
um adequacy and sufficiency so I know
that in them the in the house
subcommittee there was a great
discussion on timeliness
um there's a discussion of should it be
one hour or should it be a reasonable
time or
um uh different questions around
timeliness which was really helpful I
think when we get to the issue of why
some folks are getting mental hygiene
products in prisons and jails and some
aren't it really comes down to that
there's either a really a system or
there's kind of a lack of a system and
so the the women's prison and many jails
have a a good practice a best practice
where there's a standard amount in
practice that that are handed out or
doled out in efficient manner ever you
know at the beginning of a four week
period at the so that it meets with a
menstrual cycle
that's probably good for um prisons and
jails I imagine because it's it's an
orderly fashion it's a functional system
it's also really good for people who are
incarcerated who menstruate because
um they can count on those paths and
tampons they can count on having them
um ahead of time they don't have to wait
until they're
um on their period to ask and then on
the other side is just a few gels that
are not in that system and it's really
more of an ad hoc system
and someone has to wait until they're in
need to ask wait for a corrections
officer to come around ask for it wait
to receive it it might not be in the
amount or the type they need and they
might go through that an hour later and
need more and so it's kind of a system
or an ad hoc system
and sufficiency or adequacy really and
timeliness are the issues having enough
and having them at the right time and so
the Senate version that actually puts a
minimum number and to be clear this is a
minimum number not a maximum or a or a
specific only to that number it's a
minimum number I think that's the only
way that a number could actually achieve
adequacy without as Tony had mentioned
having to litigate what adequacy means
or what sufficiency means because a
corrections officer might think
three tampons is sufficient or adequate
and so if you're debating sufficiency
and adequacy you're putting the very
people we're trying to fix this issue
for in a position where they would have
to litigate that
so I think
um
by putting a number to it
uh you know we thought about costs and I
don't think that that's going to be
burning some costs based on what I've
heard from superintendents we thought
about safety issues and that's why
there's language in there about safety
and not having too many products in a
Cell that's actually very near identical
language in the House and Senate version
but it does come down to um you know
perhaps it would be burdensome for a
jail to keep track of that number if
they kept to that ad hoc system but
that's really the point what we're
trying to move away from is that it
would no longer be burdensome to make
sure they got a basic or minimum number
if they implemented A system that we see
as a best practice at the prison in many
other jails
so those are the three differences I'm
happy to take questions I lay them out
here but happy to take questions
see none thank you very much for your
testimony in preparing this for us
and the chair I recognizes commissioner
Helen Hanks
good afternoon a honorable committee for
the record Helen Hanks commissioner of
the Department of Corrections
um uh it's really a an honor and a
privilege when the state takes the
Department of Corrections long-standing
practice and says this is so good it
should be in law so whether you choose
the house bill version or the Senate
version we will continue to do the right
thing by those who are in our facilities
and who menstruate
um I do want to just point out the
differences between the two bill you we
just talked about key areas for the
Department are the definitions of a
menstrual hygiene product that does have
meaning we don't want products and that
could be used as a tool to actually
throw blood at people on line 16 of the
Senate Bill I just want to point out
this is a unintentional error on line 16
it says the superintendent of each
County correctional facility
that should say the warden or director
of each State Correctional Facility
just as a note
um
and the inclusion of of Youth is
obviously incredibly important so
whichever bill is ultimately the final
bill you know the department is here to
be a resource to acknowledge that this
should not be a conversation in
correctional facilities and that
um
I was sitting here thinking as I do
spontaneously every day that the
question of adequate amount versus
saying I'm going to give you 20 of these
types of products if you give 20 of
these types of products at a you know
systematic period of time in a month
you're not dealing with someone who you
know there's always going to be someone
who does harm right I mean that's what
we see across every profession in the
state of New Hampshire whether you're a
teacher a counselor or doctor wherever
you are I was thinking about the term
adequacy and really putting a lot of
thought to it you can have a person say
well you have three today you can come
back and I'll give you three tomorrow
you can have four today you have one
today
um I think we're all just trying to make
sure that this conversation and our law
has a passes are reasonableness test and
and tries to make sure the person that's
going to do harm
doesn't do harm in the best way that we
can handle it for women in these
situations in our correctional
facilities and I appreciate you all for
thinking about this topic in a way that
we wouldn't have anticipated spending so
much time on but ultimately we're a
resource for you we want to be that and
we would appreciate the definition
remaining the same the correction that I
pointed out and the specific inclusion
of Youth uh youth women who are
menstruating in our state with that and
certainly Avail myself to any questions
or assistance as you navigate this topic
thank you Mr chairman thank you
commissioner I just wanted to clarify
because I've been taking notes since our
whole conversation so 622 37a
you would like the verbiage to say the
warden or superintendent of each is that
the words that you said representative
thank you for that it's Warden or
director director in state corrections
we do not have superintendents thank you
thank you for that question
and I just have one quick question
um
I'm sure that you've examined it but
just for for me how is 20 adequate are
we or is that generally an adequate
amount that the key important part here
is the second following sentence that
we're giving out a minimum a combination
of 20 items and that second sentence
that says an individual May request
additional products
mostly based on their their person at no
cost that's important
um that's critical they mean something
together they don't mean something apart
and so whichever you decide the approach
has to say
we are reasonable we know you may need
more I will add at the state level I
don't know what the county level we give
these at no cost and in our commissary
you can choose to buy more right we just
don't want this to be a conversation
when people are trying to seek
rehabilitation
would it not
and I understand what you're saying
where it says um an individual May
request
um but oftentimes we know that when we
request things we are told no
um would it not be better to say shall
be supplied at their request versus the
stronger intent yes
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chair thank you
commissioner um just I just wanted to
ask um and I don't know if you can
answer this for the county facilities
um but the if we're dispensing 20
whether pads tampons whatever
um are the inmates allowed to keep those
in their cell all 20 does would that
happen both in the state and County
facilities I can speak to the the State
Department of Corrections that's you
keep them in yourself okay I couldn't
speak to the county I could assume for
the county but I can tell you in state
corrections stay in your room
great travel with one on your person if
you're going to a class okay thank you
yeah that was I just was thinking about
the timeliness I mean it's good to great
that we've given 20 but if they don't
have access to them so thank you thank
you
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman representative Murphy touched
on my question but when you what so you
get 20. is that
20 at the beginning of the month or I
was a little bit confused by something
you said or do you get doled out that
20. representative wheeler I appreciate
the question I didn't actually say those
things we give them in a steady supply
to the to the person in need
um we have a a process but again we have
also a total property policy which is a
a larger conversation for comparative
and a person can have in their room a
certain amount of property so that point
of not having so much excess of this
product but there's also rules and
regulations around excess of other
products too not to be a hazard
um so on a regular basis even if it was
daily we have a system that allows us to
respond but people are not at a point
where they only have 20 products in
their room and then on you know day 21
they don't have any it's a it's a
rolling availability just says you it's
as normative in our Correctional
Facility as it would be at home for a
person who menstruates
you're welcome
and everything none thank you very much
for your testimony commissioner thank
you for service to the state has anyone
else wishing to testify in this bill who
has not done so
it'll be nana here by closes public
hearing
let me see 125 230. it won't be in
recess until 2 30.
foreign
at this point I'm opening the house
hearing uh the Committee hearing on
Senate Bill 268 and I recognize Senator
D'Alessandro to introduce his bill
foreign
distinguished members of the committee
uh I'm Senator Lou dalessandro I
represent District 20. Manchester Awards
2 3 4 10 11 and 12. and I come before
you as the prime sponsor of Senate bill
268.
which will be called Max's law to honor
a Portsmouth police dog that was killed
in the line of duty during a trading
accident
the Massachusetts legislature passed
dero's law which is sibilant to Senate
bill 268.
this Emergency Medical Services are not
allowed to provide medical services to
law enforcement canines
this bill will allow that to take place
and a beginning family is here who's
who's
son was involved in the incident there
is an amendment
that will be offered the amendment is a
technical one that doesn't change it
doesn't change the uh the bill at all we
worked hard on getting this done this
was a late file uh we brought it in
through rules we got it through the the
Senate with without any problems it was
a unanimous vote
and as I say Patrick Denise gandina here
that I believe that they will testify we
have a representative from the
Massachusetts legislature here
who will testify
it uh
with that
Mr chair I
will address any queries that you you
might have but I'm pleased to be here I
thank you very much for being on time
can't beat that and uh great to be here
with my former colleagues from the house
I was in the house many years ago and uh
had a good trip so with that Mr chairman
I'll address any questions that you
might have and as I said thank you very
much for your attention
thank you for uh offering us the
privilege to hear this bill and for your
service in the house of Senate and um I
don't believe we have any questions for
you we'll just go ahead and listen to
the uh to the family thank you thank you
the chair recognizes Patrick and Denise
Gannon
good afternoon
we are Patrick and Denise Gannon
thank you for hearing us this afternoon
we are the parents of canine Sergeant
Sean Gannon you have all received a
picture three actually in front of you
this is Sean with his canine Nero when
they were in active duty
he was murdered in the line of duty on
April 12 2018 we're coming up on five
years in Marston Mills Massachusetts
while serving an arrest warrant on a
career criminal with over 125 priors
Sean was 32 years old and married for
just a year and a half prior to his
murder he was well educated with degrees
in criminal justice psychology Spanish a
master's degree in emergency management
and many certifications
Sean served as Yarmouth Police
Department's first canine narcotics
Handler with k-9-4
he led the Emergency Management unit for
ypd and was a member of the proactive
anti-crime team for the same Department
following Thor's retirement Sean
acquired a new partner canine Nero
a young Belgian Malinois trained and
certified in tracking building and area
searches criminal apprehension evidence
recovery crowd control and Handler
protection
Shawna Nero worked together for a year
and a half before Sean's murder
on the day of the murder
a team of officers that included Shawna
Nero were deployed to serve an arrest
warrant completely unaware
that the arrest would turn into a
barricade situation
the perpetrator was hiding behind
insulation in the tiny house of an attic
the attic was unfinished it was a crawl
space
Nero was on the 30-inch lead and pulls
Sean to a piece of insulation that led
to another piece of crawl space in the
Attic when Sean pulled back the piece of
insulation to view the space the killer
shot Sean in the head and shot Nero in
the face
Sean died on impact
Nero's bullet passed through his face
dissected his trachea and landed in his
shoulder where the bullet Still Remains
while de-escalation tactics were
implemented in an effort to prompt the
killer from his hiding place behind the
insulation
Nero lay critically injured in the Attic
swallowing his own blood for three hours
after the murder was coaxed from the
house and placed into custody
to master canine handlers cut a roof
a hole in the roof of the house to
rescue canine Nero from the attic space
under Massachusetts law at the time
emergency medical care and
transportation to a veterinary hospital
for Nero was not permitted the unit
Commander at the scene made quote one of
the most decisions of difficult
decisions of his life end quote and
placed Nero into his Cruiser
an emergency medicine physician who was
also at the scene went into the cruiser
and together they rushed Nero to a
Veterinary Hospital
by this time Nero was gasping for air
The Physician intubated Nero with a
drinking straw which was the only tool
that he had available to him in the
cruiser to that enabled Nero to breathe
the prolonged delay and access to
treatment seriously jeopardized Nero's
chance of survival and inflicted hours
of suffering for the dog
in fact you wouldn't have those two
recovery pictures of Nero today had that
unit Commander not enabled Nero to be
transported in a cruiser Nero would have
died
Nero underwent surgery that night and
spent weeks with canine officers
sleeping with Nero in his cage Around
the Clock
Nero was a despondent until Sean's Widow
placed one of Sean's shirts under Nero's
head for the first time Nero's tale
slowly wagged when he smelled Sean's
scent
when Nero was released from the hospital
one of the first things Nero did was
climb into his Cruiser and licked the
headrest where Sean sent remained these
are illustrations of the bond that
exists between a canine and its Handler
at the time Nero was fairly new in his
career as a patrol drug but
unfortunately the extent of his injuries
combined with the traumatic
circumstances forced Nero into early
retirement
delays in care of this nature combined
with a possibly unnecessary retirement
do not need to be repeated for any
canine in any law enforcement agency
the events that occurred came at a
significant cost to the Yarmouth Police
Department the acquisition of a canine
animal the extensive initial and ongoing
training for both the canine and its
Handler in addition to the Daily care
and support requires substantial
monetary Investments these Investments
are completely lost when a wounded
canine cannot receive timely care that
could result in recovery and a return to
duty
the emergency care and transportation of
a canine that's wounded in the line of
duty are cost savings measures
since its passage in Massachusetts
Nero's law has been invoked twice once
in July and most recently in December
there is a need for a law of this nature
in Massachusetts teaching and training
is ongoing for Nero's law across our
cities and towns
canines live and work and die for their
handlers as we saw in the case of the
canine kit when he dove into uh
he saw what officers did not see
initially and Dove right into the
gunfire and save three officers lives
kit was killed instantly
they work 24 7
365 days a year
and if the officer has a family the
canine becomes a member of that family
so I ask you
which one of you would let a beloved
family member
who serves the public
suffer and be close to death
and not rush
to acquire immediate emergency
medical help
there are some things that have happened
that we can't change
but this lies something we can change
and we have changed Massachusetts Rhode
Island Maine Connecticut's effort is
underway
across the country we see rapidly
growing interest among First Responders
veterinarians in the general public for
needed legislation like Max's law
in fact 46 percent of all states have
either passed a version of Max's law or
have similar efforts underway
Colorado led the way
we hope that New Hampshire will follow
suit with Max's law to support canines
their handlers law enforcement and the
public
in the posthumous crato of our son Sean
let's do the right thing
thank you very much for hearing us this
afternoon do you have any questions at
all for us
I'm seeing none thank you very much for
sharing your story and on behalf of the
committee we're sorry for your loss
uh this time the chair calls
representative ziaros
I got that right close enough sir
get back
good afternoon
chair
through you to the members um
it's hard for me to sit here and listen
to that
so before I
became a state representative
I was Sean's
boss
so I like to tell you my story and uh
thank you for sitting next to me
so I
respectfully urge you to issue a
favorable report
on your bill known as Max's law
it has very special meaning to me
it's very personal
uh Massachusetts passed it last year
on the anniversary of Sean's murder
and I'll tell you a little bit of the
story you heard from Mrs Gannon and Mr
Gannon I mean those are the parents of a
murdered police officer
that I sent on that call
it was so Nero's law
is inspired out of tragic events that
took place on April 12th 2018. back on
that day I was the Deputy Chief of
Police
for the Yarmouth Police Department
we received information that a violent
career Criminal
with 125 prior charges
was at a house
he was wanted on outstanding warrants
we had information that he was armed
illegally and we knew him we knew he was
dangerous
and I sent those officers on that call
and I heard them screaming on the radio
for help
so I raced as fast as I could to the
scene
I learned that canine Sergeant Sean
Gannon had been shot in the head
and taken from the scene
and then I learned through my radio that
he had died
at the hospital despite everyone doing
their best and looking back he probably
died at the house
but they rescued him and did everything
they could to save him
but meanwhile the shooter was in the
house
and so was Nero
and um
the SWAT team came and
help came from everywhere and I was
right there the whole time
from three o'clock in the afternoon till
probably one in the morning
and Mrs Gannon talked about it
but after the suspect finally gave up
we knew that he had murdered my officer
my brother
and we knew that he shot Nero
and he walked out of that building with
his hands up
I'll never forget that sight and that
feeling and
seeing our offices take him into custody
and but the mission wasn't done we
needed to find narrow
and we needed to make sure there was no
more killers in that house
so the SWAT team went in and they do
what they do
but I'll never forget the sight of them
carrying out Nero you know he was still
alive
foreign
you know gasping for for air he was
bleeding to death choking to death and
nobody
could legally help him
all the EMTs all the paramedics all the
ambulances sitting there
um the hands were tied
so
the police took over as as mentioned a
doctor from the SWAT team jumped in back
of a cruiser
Peter McClellan um
a retired Yarmouth officer who was
called to the scene
because we knew if Nero was alive
somebody would have to handle him
and Peter was
a canine Handler
he raised Nero as a puppy
and he gave Nero to Sean
yeah
so a Barnesville police officer drove a
cruiser
a doctor sat in the back
Nero was on Peter's lap
and they did the best they could to keep
him alive
and he was transported to the Veterinary
Hospital
because there was no other option
and for a week
police officers never left Nero
Peter McClellan slept in the cage with
him at the hospital
canine officers guided the building
and I was there when when that picture
was taken that you may have
we knew that Nero was coming out
we ordered Sean's Cruiser to be brought
to the scene Sean's Cruiser
and when Nero came out I was standing
right there
and he was so skinny
he's covered in scars stitches
and I saw his eyes you know staring at
Sean's Cruiser and he was looking for
Sean
and then I open the back door where the
Nero goes and he jumped right in
then he started licking Sean's headrest
so
after we laid Sean to rest and after I
handed the folded flag to Mrs Gannon
at his grave
we just kept working and doing what we
could to to heal our officers and honors
on
and we wrote A bill called Nero's bill
with the help of veterinarians and and
uh
people and police officers and and rep
Crocker was the the representative at
the time I was a police officer
but it didn't pass
so that was a message to me after 40
Years of serving
um
I needed to retire from the job that I
loved and run for office
to do something I've never done
probably a lot like you you know we
we run for office to to Serve and
Protect and to help and for me it was to
right or wrong
and um
it's not easy to make a law
there's no such thing as a no-brainer
it failed the first time and then High
filed it
and honestly I never worked so hard to
to bring people together to get
co-sponsors
tell the story of Sean just kind of like
we're doing today
and uh
for me you know as a rookie
representative in Massachusetts
we got it done in 10 months
and I thank Governor Baker and all my
colleagues for coming together to do the
right thing
and then there was a matter of well
where do we do the signing of this bill
that took so long and so much blood
and uh I asked Governor Baker if he
would come to Yarmouth police
headquarters
and sign it on the day of the tragedy
and he said Steve I would be honored but
is that okay with the ganons
and they said yes
so if you can just picture uh four years
to the day
Governor Baker lieutenant governor
Polito all my colleagues
Mrs Gannon missed again and
Sean's Widow
and Nero and about 50 police dogs and
everybody was there
and not at Yarmouth Police Headquarters
but behind it
where Sean and I stood in the woods
about five years ago and he said Deputy
what if we cleared these Woods
and we made a canine training center
because we should be able to train our
dogs right here
and then he was murdered
so we cleared those woods and we built a
one million dollar Training Center
it's called the canine sergeant Sean M
Gannon police canine Center
and that is where the bill was signed in
that building
and I'll never forget it
it's doing the right thing
and as they mentioned since then
two
since then three dogs have been shot in
Massachusetts
so Nero was one
canine kit was a Braintree dog
was involved with a shootout and he took
the bullets instead of the officers and
he was murdered
and they could not treat them
because the bill wasn't signed yet
but once the bill was passed
um
canine Frankie estate police canine was
shot to death
saving his Troopers
and I got a text that night
from the state police
saying rep alexandros
we're just leaving the crematorium
with
Frankie's body
but we want to thank you for
passing that law because he was treated
he was transported in an ambulance and
he was given every chance to live
and he died with dignity
so we're here to ask you to support this
bill
to give you some of the back story
these animals are not just animals
they're they're police officers their
partners
they deserve our protection
and I ask for your support
thank you
and if you have any questions I'd be
happy to answer
I don't see any thank you very much for
your testimony
thank you sir
this point the chair recognizes Mr Bill
Werner
good afternoon
representative Roy members of the
committee thanks so much for giving us
some time today I'm sorry I'm gonna have
to sit with my back a little to this
side I don't fit in this chair so
respectfully maybe wider chairs
um
thank you so much
so my name is Bill Werner I'm here
representing the Portsmouth Police
Department
in support of Senate bill 268.
um first and foremost I'd like to
um just touch on where we're asking that
you accept the bill as it sits before
you just with one amendment that Senator
D'Alessandro had referenced
if I could direct your attention to line
number 20.
the last two words in that sentence
ambulance services we'd like to strike
those and replace them with the word
treatment
so that is the the One technical
amendment that was mentioned earlier
going around the room I I was able to
submit a written testimony for two
individuals who couldn't be here today
both who are in support of the bill both
Brandon skogland who represents the
Elliott hospital and EMS
as well as Benjamin Foster who is a
canine Sergeant with Manchester Police
Department so their written testimonies
are coming around
as a canine Handler in the city of
Portsmouth as well as Opera an operator
on the Seacoast Emergency Response Team
I've had the distinct opportunity to
work with these animals that are beyond
amazing in their abilities
all around New Hampshire we have
operational canines demonstrating their
capabilities from our detection dogs who
can
small smell the smallest amounts of
Narcotics explosives or accelerants
to our tracking dogs who are asked to
find Alzheimer's patients or small
children who have wandered sometimes
miles from their homes
to our Patrol dogs who help locate and
assist in the apprehension of violent
criminals to even our comfort dogs who
are there for people in their time of
need in a way that humans simply cannot
be
as a Handler of a patrol dog and you
have a picture of my dog also named
Frankie
this Senate bill has a very different
meaning for me as opposed to that of
maybe a Department's Administration who
may be looking at the financial aspect
of losing a dog
or societies want to protect all dogs
because we love them
as a patrolman and a member of the SWAT
team I'm frequently called on sometimes
in the middle of the night
to respond to the most dangerous
situations and once on scene I asked
Frankie to quite literally become the
tip of the spear
I asked him to go first into the unknown
while as humans are 40 plus feet behind
them sometimes I even ask Frankie to go
in alone while I wait safely out of
sight
and without question fearlessly Frankie
will head off into the dark unknown
because I asked him to
and he'll do this so that he can first
encounter whatever danger maybe hiding
in a corner or behind a door or lurking
in the shadows so that he can take the
bullet or the knife or the punch or the
kick so that his humans don't have to
and this bill will be our way of showing
these brave animals that we appreciate
their efforts to keep us safe and that
we're willing to do
whatever we can to help them in their
time and need
so I would ask you all that you find
Senate Bill 268
ought to pass and thanks so much for
your consideration I I can also answer
any questions that you may have from the
canine handlers point of view
seeing none thank you for your testimony
what would I miss representative Newman
could you just repeat what you said
about what the change is in the
amendment yes
um so line number 20 in the amendment in
yes in the in the bill that sits before
you uh line number 20
um the line reads injured in the course
of their official duties and no human
needs or needs transport or those last
two lines ambulance services we'd like
to strike those and replace it with the
word treatment
thank you
just further further clarification
because I think we're a little bit
confused on this side
um so the ambulance services that you're
seeing is on line 24 that's what you're
looking at
hey hello oh okay yeah if the members if
the members could just hold off the
technical questions we have an amendment
in the works that encompasses everything
that's being discussed I see that's
where our confusion came yeah no problem
any further questions for the officer
representative side Tech
uh as a matter of Interest how long does
it take to train an operational dog
I'm sorry representative say it again
how long does it take to train one of
these I don't know service animals so
um for most departments here in Southern
New Hampshire
we all train with the Boston police
canine training group
so for a training for a patrol dog we go
down to Boston every day for 14 weeks
dog and Handler so the certification at
the end of that 14 weeks is for the team
so if that dog were to go to a different
Handler they would have to restart that
program
once the 14 weeks is done most many dogs
many Patrol dogs here in the state are
dual certified
so they have a secondary certification
so for Frankie canine Frankie he's
secondary certification is that of
explosive ordinance detection EOD he's a
bomb dog
so we had to go back down to Boston for
a 10-week program
once those two certifications are done
the dogs will have to pass annual
certification recertifications put on by
national organizations
to keep our status with the Boston
police training group we also have to go
down to two eight hour training days a
month
and that's just formal training that
doesn't count the daily training that a
Handler will put his dog through just to
ensure that if they do get the call the
dog is is ready
all of that training is also documented
so the the pages and pages of training
sheets
reflect all of that training
thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes Stacy Ober
good afternoon chair Roy members of the
committee my name is Stacy Ober and I am
the New England manager of government
relations for the American Kennel Club
we were founded in 1884 where a
non-profit
canine club that is widely recognized
for canine breeding training and
responsible dog ownership we represent
more than 5 000 clubs across the country
including 13 here in New Hampshire
and back in 2021 AKC licensed and
sanctioned 150 events in New Hampshire
where more than 26 000 dogs participated
I'm here in support of Senate bill 268.
I want to just acknowledge that AKC
educates and supports the breeders of
these high quality dogs that are bred
for their predictable type their
instincts and their temperament to
perform these important roles
um we value the contribution that these
working dogs make to National Security
and the extraordinary role that these
dogs play in protecting the peace and
security of individuals communities and
nations against threats and we honor the
Breeders trainers and handlers of these
dogs
to ensure Public Safety and National
Security we support expanded scientific
research and breeders who ensure that
sufficient numbers of high quality
domestically bred dogs are available and
we're asking you to pass Senate 268 so
that Specialized Care is provided to
assure their well-being
I know a lay person may be contemplating
uh what would be the difference for
instance in emergently transporting a
police canine in a cruiser with the
lights on versus an ambulance that's
able to get there expediently and I just
wanted to emphasize that our emergency
medical personnel have the skills for
instance to pack a wound open an airway
do certain life-saving skills that
another you know a police officer
wouldn't necessarily have and that's the
benefit of knowing they already have the
basic skills to be able to provide life
saving treatment while the dog is being
emergently transported
I also wanted to acknowledge that our
affiliate AKC reunite works with our AKC
clubs to donate police canines to police
departments around the United States
many police K-9 units are suffering
budget cuts and they're unable to
solicit money due to town and
municipality codes and so the donations
from AKC reunite and the AKC clubs allow
the police department's need for a new
canine to become a reality a maximum of
one Grant per department and a total of
250 grants will be awarded in 2023. this
is a three to one match grant program up
to ten thousand dollars in response to
the Braintree Massachusetts police
department losing canine kit for
instance we were able to produce a check
for ten thousand dollars to go towards
replacing their police K-9 for them so I
did bring a copy of the application if
anyone's interested and it's available
online as well for anyone that might
have a community that's looking to
acquire a police canine so I thought I
would mention that as well
thank you
um do you if if you know how many
um facilities do we have in the area to
treat emergency treat canines who are
injured
that would depend on how many emergency
veterinary clinics you have
um and I expect someone behind me
probably could answer that in
Massachusetts they're kind of
geographically by region where they're
available and on the implementation of
Nero's law the protocols would lay that
out in terms of what's what's the
nearest emergency veterinary clinic to
you
thank you
representative Pro
do you know of any training for the EMTs
that are in these ambulances for the
dogs because I've only seen one course I
tried to sign up for it and it was full
before I could even get there well it's
I think it's kind of the concept of if
you build it they will come once the
bill passed in Massachusetts uh for
instance Robert Kraft made available
Gillette Stadium and they had a large
training that was put on there
um I think there were four groups of 40
that rotated through so it may not be
readily available now but I imagine that
once the bill passes again that would be
part of the implementation I know a lot
of our clubs also will donate for
instance
um canine muzzles and other equipment
that might be necessarily that's not
readily available but um the handlers
themselves would have on site for their
police K-9 that kind of equipment you
know where it would be readily available
as well
thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
the chair calls in a batchelder
foreign
good afternoon my name is Dr Cara
batchelder and I'm here in today in
support of Senate Bill 268. I've been
employed as an emergency and Critical
Care Veterinarian at the Veterinary
Emergency Center in Manchester for about
nine years and during that time I've had
the privilege of working with the
Manchester Police Department's K-9 unit
which has allowed me to see just the
unique bond that these dogs and their
handlers have and how important it is to
keep them healthy and fully able to
function at their job
so unlike your typical house family dog
these dogs are in unique high-risk
situations
that potentially can result in
life-threatening injuries or exposures
and this can include anything from
gunshot wounds stab wounds heat related
illnesses illicit drug exposures and
intoxications burn injuries and other
blunt force trauma injuries
so unfortunately in most instances our
Veterinary Community doesn't have the
resources to respond immediately to
emergencies when they occur in the
fields and as a result there's a large
gap that exists in the provision of care
for our operational canines on scene at
the point of injury and during transport
to a Veterinary facility
um the military's been using their
Medics to perform field triage
stabilization and transport of their
operational canines for quite some time
with very good results
and so while there's not an organized
Veterinary Emergency Medical Services
Program here in New Hampshire similar to
military Medics our EMTs and paramedics
are in the ideal situation
to close that Gap in care and perform
the nested Theory the necessary tasks to
stabilize the dogs in the field
so as a result when the dogs reach a
Veterinary facility their odds of the
successful recovery are significantly
increased two of my colleagues and I
attended an extensive three-day course
in Portland Maine on Advanced first aid
for operational canines the goals of
this course were to teach handlers and
emergency medical responders how to
recognize situations where pre-hospital
care was indicated how to stabilize the
dogs and try to avoid preventable deaths
so it was amazing to see during this
course how the EMS Personnel were able
to do with just a little bit of guidance
take their already existing skill set
and tools and just translate them into
canines we're working my team and I are
working with our New Hampshire EMS teams
here to set up a similar program for
training so that hopefully once we get
everything in place we can start rolling
out training for for our own handlers
and EMS
um and hopefully this will allow us to
close the gap in care and provide the
care that our operational canines in New
Hampshire deserve so I thank you for
considering Senate Bill 268 and can
certainly take any questions if there
are any
um if I could
ask you the um same question asked
before how many facilities are available
in New Hampshire to treat canines on an
emergency basis like an emergency room
type thing yeah so
um there are eight ER type of hospitals
that in theory could perform most of
these skills there are three hospitals
that are that contain Specialists so
like boarded surgeons
criticalists
anesthesiologists the the more advanced
skills and then really any general
practice could do you know your basic
stabilization if needed so especially
for up north where there's not as many
hospitals if they needed to go there
first and then be transported later to a
specialty facility that certainly is an
option is there like a rotating schedule
like which ones are open 24 hours so
that the officers know what the closest
one to them is at any given time so I'm
I have a list that I have to provide to
our Ems for once we get our training
program in place unfortunately because
there's a shortage of Veterinary staff
not every place is open 24 hours
consistently
um so we'll provide that to them so that
any first responder who who goes will
have that as part of their you know they
have EMS protocols so that could be
included in their potentially if they
need to
no further questions thank you
the chair recognizes
Justin romanello ramello
Justin romello
it's been butchered worse so thank you
good afternoon
um really just a couple clarifications
and certainly here for a question so my
name is Justin Romano I'm the chief of
the Bureau of Ems for the State of New
Hampshire we regulate all EMS providers
in the state
um so I don't have the numbers but I
will tell you what has changed in the um
in the bill before you so under the
first section which is definitions we
are removing emergency providers that
definition and we're removing treatment
definition because that's previously
defined in 153 A2 which is the
definitions for all of RSA 153.
and that's changes the order so you only
have three definitions for one for law
enforcement officer which is a b is
going to be operational canine and C
would be official duties
the only other change under definitions
would be within the law enforcement
officer section and that's referring to
the appropriate RSA that will Define
what a law enforcement officer is and
then it adds as you read in front of you
the the addition of National Guard to
that and that's what officer Warner was
uh I believe that's what you're
referring to
um and then the second change
uh that actually off somewhere I was
referring to is under section two
and it's the last uh phrase in section
two it removes ambulance services
and it adds treatment and that would be
in line with other language within the
language there's no such thing as
ambulance services in the state it's
treatment and transport if that makes
sense
and then I'm certainly available to
answer any questions I think there's a
couple questions that very previously
asked that I could answer and put more
guidance to
true if you heard a question you've
wanted to answer so the way we see this
uh once if if this is passed uh it will
fall within our normal EMS protocols and
it will be what we call a prerequisite
protocol which is an additional protocol
that EMS providers have available to
them through their licensed units
and what that allows for is
relationships and so it encourages
relationships between the officers so
the law enforcement officers that have
the canines and our EMS providers and
the units as well as you know the
hospitals so who's going to be available
24 hours a day and other services that
may be needed so there's an additional
application process for our prerequisite
protocols so the division as well as the
boards that
um that provide guidance for EMS within
the state all understand that everybody
is has the appropriate oversight the
relationships are there so there's
there's nobody kind of left high and dry
and so to your question as far as the
number of hospitals the way I I view the
prerequisite protocol it's going to
outline all the hospitals that are
available and then as an example for
Manchester Manchester fire as a
non-transport EMS agency in AMR as a
transport agency will understand what
hospital that the canine Handler prefers
for their canine what's available for a
given time so all this will be kind of
ironed out within that prerequisite
protocol in that application process
um
that's really the only other
clarification unless there's any
questions I certainly can answer
anything for the EMS system
representative sailing
thank you I'm I'm just sorry just
thinking back about all the different
testimony
um I recognize that obviously if there's
a human who needs transport to an
emergency room as well as a canine that
the human should get it first
is it possible within an ambulance to
have them both go and that's just a
practical I don't I've not been inside
an ambulance except to take my kids on
tours so sure so there's there's many
different types of ambulances that are
out there some are easier to transport
multiple patients
um than than others I think that um
you know the treatment and transport are
two different things right and so the
ability to treat is the one piece and
then how we can transport you know and I
think there's flexibilities within that
so if there was a situation where
um there's no access to an ambulance
immediately and and the K-9 needs to be
transported we have the benefits of of
having a left and right to treat
um and then we could find potentially
other vehicles at that time but I think
what this bill does
um is it provides that left and right to
to really say this is at the EMT level
what treatment modalities can be done at
the advanced level at the paramedic
level where we didn't have that before
um so it wasn't only just the ability to
whether to treat and transport or not it
was it was this really was kind of the
Wild Wild West right and so we've seen
in other states where this provides that
left and right
um and yes absolutely if if there was a
case where
um we need the the transport you know
two people we see a person in a canine
we certainly could do that
yeah just um
they go to two different places
obviously sure so
if they were transporting to um
obviously the human would be dropped off
and then the canine would drop wherever
the is that yeah I mean I think that
it's
um
you know I what we certainly don't want
to do
um in any type of you know whether it's
admin rule that we create well for this
or protocol is is say that you have to
do this in a particular order like
there's got to be some flexibilities for
our providers and I think our our Pro
EMS protocols and our patient care
protocols allow for that flexibility
um and and what's best at the time for
all patients
um and what's available at the time for
all transport modalities and that sort
of thing so
um you know I think we have that
flexibility in here to ensure
everybody's receiving the care that they
need
um and and have access to the transport
mechanisms and you know my thought is in
in some of these instances you might you
know have if you know you have a
potential for a couple patients you're
going to have some ambulances standing
by potentially assuming it's available
in the system
um again that treatment is key I think
in any case there's there's you know if
we didn't have the ability to treat
appropriately with the training you know
if there wasn't an ambulance available
you know our providers you know might
have first been a little flustered at
the time where now they have treatment
modalities and potentially have
treatment when I was in place so they
could stabilize until you know that next
ambulance is available
okay
would we I'm wondering if we need to add
something in the amendment you were
talking about that just says
that sort of gives the flexibility in
terms of co-transporting if that's the
only option I just don't know if we need
to add that in I'd prefer to leave the
flexibility to the commanders on the
scene as long as it's not prohibited for
them to make the call
um on the ground versus dictating from
here but we'll look at it
representative Muse had a question
I understand that in Massachusetts
um there's some training that was
required on the part of ambulance uh
drivers I and the the effective date on
this particular bill is immediately upon
passage
um given the experience in Massachusetts
that you've had a chance to see
um uh what is your opinion around the
effective date should we leave it as is
or should we move it sure
so I think
much different than how this how this is
written compared to what Massachusetts
did
um I think
so Massachusetts basically said that
every licensed unit every provider has
to must uh treat and transport a K-9 and
I think that whereas this may it allows
for us to put it into a prerequisite
protocol and allows for a licensed unit
that may support canine operations so
we'll use Manchester as an example it
allows them to provide care so we're not
going to have 301 Services license units
providing care we're giving them the
flexibility to decide if they want to do
that and so with that again I keep
saying the prerequisite protocol we can
outline what what skills are going to be
or um sorry what scope of practice and
treatment modalities are going to be
allowed at any particular level and then
it's the Departments that that's
choosing to apply for this it's their
job didn't go out and get that training
and I think we could support it as a
state we can provide we can't certainly
support the entire state to provide
training we don't have do the way this
is written but we can provide access to
the various programs that are out there
and there are quite a few
um and so like a department that just
has EMTs they're not going to need a
three-day course you know Massachusetts
I believe their entire curriculum with
the Practical portion and the the online
portions about four hours
but I think that different with
Massachusetts this is allowing our
agencies to do it if they wish and our
providers to do it through those
agencies but it's not every single
service is going to have they have the
opportunity but they don't have to do it
if that makes sense right
and one quick follow-up
um I'm not sure you answered my question
just around the effective date uh sure
so
so as of once this becomes effective our
departments and license units will have
the ability to to do it and then uh we
will give them the protocols and all
that through our normal protocols so
even though it's effective at that point
we they still have the opportunity to
apply for it and we still would be able
to satisfy anything we don't need I
don't believe we need any type of grace
period the only other piece to this
um in
it's only from my perspective is that I
believe that the board of veterinary
medicine is going to have to make
modifications to their administrative
rules and we will work with them to put
in interim rules but again that's just
from my perspective because they have
the Veterinarian Practice Act that's
going to have to they're going to have
to have an administrative rule the 308
that's going to allow for EMS providers
to be waived from providing care under
that act
um we there's other avenues of EMS care
that we do that one of those is mobile
integrated Healthcare we have a waiver
in place with the Department of Health
and Human Services that waives licensed
EMS providers from having to be licensed
as Home Health Care agents and that's to
facilitate us providing community
paramedicine and mobile integrated
Healthcare and I see us I see the board
of veterinary medicine and oplc having
to add in administrative rules under 308
to facilitate that
um but as far as timelines I certainly
can't speak for another agency
thank you
represent Peru
so
my question is
yep we're gonna
my department police department has a
dog so we're probably going to jump in
on this but if there's a department that
doesn't have a dog probably saying hey
we don't need to do this but the next
town over comes in and their dogs there
if they're not
in that protocol are we prohibiting them
from transporting
I don't think so I think
um
my colleagues in the back State Police
they they have 20 operational dogs
throughout the state they're all over
the place I think that departments that
cover larger areas will have to
um and we'll certainly work with with
them to Foster those relationships but
they're going to have to have
relationships with multiple multiple
other departments and I think you know
down the road I was speaking with again
and uh before before the testimony
um I think you know once we'll down the
road we'll find that there might be some
baseline protocol that we can issue like
CPR you know that maybe every department
will or every provider should learn that
but I think at first starting with this
seeing how many departments are are
going to take part in this you know
really finding out how many dogs and
departments are out there that that own
canines uh or operational canines I
think uh
one point or down the road we might get
to where it's a general protocol to to
take care of that but for right now it's
going to be you know if if Nashua has
has a a canine uh you know obviously
Nashua fire department has a
non-transport AMR as a transport but it
might be adventitious if they find that
they go to other communities you know to
to provide you know may or SWAT team
goes out to provide services to
Merrimack well maybe Merrimack Fire
would would need to to take part of this
and we have other prerequisite protocols
specifically going back to mobile and
creative Healthcare where multiple
departments are taking part in in that
specific protocol so I really think that
it can work
oh
so what I would like to see is that they
can at least transport they may not be
able to apply any care but I think just
putting him in the bus and transporting
is better than letting them sit there or
on the back of the cruiser so I actually
made that note and so I I appreciate
that um I I was thinking about the same
thing so I mean the the bill as written
right uh and if if it goes into RSA it
will allow for the treatment and
transport so any any ambulance so we
have 476 ambulances give or take away
about now 167 transport and license
transport in a unit so that gives them
the ability to transport it makes that
appropriate and and so I what I could
see is going back to the Nashville
example so Nashville SWAT team they
they're a licensed non-transport service
in the in the state their Medics could
actually take part in this prerequisite
protocol and so it's it's allowing their
Medics to be the treatment perspective
and then AMR as the the contract that
non-contractor transport service has the
transport they work synergistically
together and and they can injured canine
gets to the appropriate resource so I
think that we don't need to make any
modifications to facilitate that that's
here
um but absolutely it would be I didn't
want to see a rule prohibiting no I
don't I don't think so at all sir
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony you've been very
informative are you aware of any good
reason as to why it's currently illegal
to transport a critically injured canine
so
um from the Bureau of EMS division of
fire standard training EMS in in within
153 and 5900 I do not see anything
however in learning more about this what
is prohibitive right now is the
Veterinarian Practice Act which is
um you know through the the the sorry
the vets that I would say is prohibitive
because that's saying specifically that
any treatment is is required to be a
veterinarian or a veterinarian clinic
technician so
I think that what this bill will do is
make sure that there's some sort of
waiver in place for our providers to
provide that care which into the
veterinarian care act but then it also
provides that left and right I made
mention of earlier like I think you know
our Protocols are robust for human
patients
um and it allows you know our providers
to to treat all patients of State
Statewide EMS protocols
um and and we could do a lot in
we need that left and right I think for
our canines there's a reason why there's
a Board of Medicine in in that sort of
airport of veterinarian care so I think
it's important and I think that's why
it's it's much neat
thank you for your testimony thank you
oh
so is that something we should put in
this bill that repeals that veterinarian
part I don't I know my opinion I don't
want to I don't think we need to repeal
it I just think I think what this RSA
will do and we've seen in other places I
made mention the mih piece so 153 you
know that's obviously it's an RSA it's a
law and that's going to facilitate
change within the administrative rules
for the veterinarian boards
um and so I think this is fine the way
it is because it's a law even though
it's a law that governs you know EMS I
still think it needs to be applied to
those administrative rules because I'd
hate to run into a roadblock I don't
think I've I've looked into it I've
spoken to my colleagues I think I don't
think we need to change anything so
I appreciate your time thank you does
anyone else wishing to testify who's not
testified on this bill
seeing Nana hereby closest public
hearing
that
only if you're going to clean up
at this point I'm open to public hearing
on Senate bill 251.
and recognize Senator Whitley
if everyone could please move out hello
oh thank you very much
I appreciate it
thank you
no problem you can't have this dog
somebody
great thank you so much thank you Mr
chair good afternoon again members of
the committee for the record my name is
Becky Whitley and I'm honored to serve
Senate District 15 which includes
Concord Beau Penacook and Hopkinton
so today I am proud to introduce Senate
Bill 251 establishing a committee to
study the long-term impact of the New
Hampshire Adult Parole system folks in
this committee may be well versed in
what the system does but if not
probation and parole is actually
designed to lower prison populations and
help people succeed in the community but
we have new data available to us that is
suggesting it might have the opposite
effect
the Council of state government again
who was actually just recently here in
the state their Justice Center recently
engaged Corrections and Community
Supervision leaders in 50 states to
develop the first complete picture of
how probation and parole violations make
up States prison populations the Council
of State government's analysis showed
that 45 percent of State Prison
admissions Nationwide are actually due
to violations of probation or parole for
new offenses or technical violations
so folks may be well aware that
technical violations such as missing
appointments with supervision officers
or failing drug tests account for nearly
one-fourth of all state prison
admissions I think that was a pretty
startling statistic when I heard it and
I was pretty shocked about it but
actually what was even more startling to
me was the statistic in New Hampshire
whereas nationally it's 45 percent of
our prison population are due to these
probation violations in New Hampshire 60
percent of State Prison admissions are
due to supervision violations and I
think that disparity with the rest of
the country tells me that it's really
time to just study this issue in New
Hampshire to make sure that the entire
system has the impact and the effect
that it was designed to have
I think a committee uh could answer
questions like how many people in New
Hampshire are on probation or parole how
are technical violations handled in New
Hampshire compared to other states what
impact does supervision violations have
on our local jails in New Hampshire in
terms of cost how do New Hampshire
policies impact the length of time that
people are on probation and parole what
types of new offenses are people on
supervision being sent to prison for
what has New Hampshire done to scale up
implementation of supervision practice
practices and programs designed to
actually reduce new Criminal behavior
and of course what's important for this
legislature to consider is how much do
we invest annually in supervision
and how much of the supervision
violations actually cost our state
so I think it's also important to take
the opportunity to re to review best
practices what does the research tells
us that is most effective and for this
legislator to make recommendations and
practices that will help deliver better
outcomes for people who are on uh or
under supervision for families for our
communities to ensure that the all the
money that we do spend on this system is
used efficiently
I'm happy to take any questions but I am
certainly not an expert on this issue
um I think it's worthy of study based on
this uh data that we have seen but I am
happy to take any questions that I ask
for the committee's support of this Bill
thank you thank you Senator
um you probably are an expert on
scheduling do you think that we will
have enough time to give this a serious
look between now and the deadline or do
you think this would be better as a
commission
so we did put I uh thank you for that
question we did put it as a committee I
think
um commissions can be you know they have
their benefits and having more people at
the table but they can take longer I
think um we have all the data at our
fingertips we just have to collate it
which is why we thought a committee was
better suited to do that
thank you for the question
representative wheeler last question of
the day Mr chairman and I thank you for
uh recognizing me so my promises
thank you but I just wanted you to
repeat the statistic that you said at
the beginning of your testimony it was
45 to 60 in the state but what was
um so the it was the council state
government their analysis said that 45
of State Prison admissions Nationwide
are due to violations of probation or
parole for new offenses or technical
violations but in New Hampshire 60 of
State Prison admissions are due to
supervision violations so it's a pretty
dramatic difference
representative Muse
thank you for taking my question
um are you aware that the legislative
budget assistant did a pretty
comprehensive review of the parole
system I think it was in 2019 and
um have you had a chance to look at that
and do you think it would be something
that would factor into what you would
like this commission to do yeah I'm
aware of it
um and I think it would absolutely
inform the work of the committee thank
you for pointing that out yeah
so you know further questions thank you
thank you
and the chair recognizes Mr Joseph Les
Collins
thank you members of the committee Mr
chair
my name is Joseph Wisconsin I will be
representing the American civil
liberties Union and myself in full
support of this Senate Bill 251
you heard many statistics and data
points about the parole system
specifically for New Hampshire that I
don't want to go over again what I do
want to highlight though is the fact
that New Hampshire does rank in the
bottom 10 percent for
four monthly admissions Across the
Nation
in New Hampshire I know that we strive
for excellence so to be in the the
bottom of the the nation especially for
a statistic like that I think is is
quite embarrassing and problematic for
the New Hampshire community
the as we heard like around 50 or more
of people that are admitted each month
to the New Hampshire prison is for a
violation of parole
into the cost of sixty four thousand
dollars annually uh myself when I first
started uh my prison sentence it was
only twenty two thousand dollars it's at
sixty four thousand dollars now annually
to the New Hampshire Community payers to
uh to fund uh the cost of incarcerating
people and I think that we have
alternative solutions that could be used
one of them being the halfway house
system where there is a seven day
sanction that is allowed for individuals
uh for violating their parole instead of
sending them back to the prison system
and last year alone uh it was used it
was not used once
and so I think that we need to take a
look at some of the ways that we are uh
applying Corrections and are we backing
the system up or are we uh creating
blockages for people uh while they are
trying to transition
one of the last things I would like to
uh to say in closing is that last year
while we were working on the study
committee bill for the truth and
sentencing as a matter of fact I
received a letter from the parole
department that had stated uh that had
what they had done is they had backdated
uh supervisor fees to the day that I had
come out of prison my parole officer
when I first came home had recognized
that I did a lot of volunteer work and
chose not to charge me supervisor fees
to remain out in the community while I
was doing the volunteer work through
diversion works and and a mentorship
program however I got a letter that
backdated it to the day and said that I
owed that money in full or I would be in
violation of My Parole which essentially
means that if I didn't pay that money in
full I would have gone back to prison
regard even though I was in the middle
of the work that I was doing
for some people on parole that that I
just would like to paint a picture of
what that does getting a letter like
that that's that that's panic panic sets
in immediately for some people which
then starts uh um starts to overwhelm
their sense of logic and reasoning and
after that Panic they start to compare
you know the maybe the negative
experiences they had with the
incarceration system as opposed to what
they have built out and then that sets a
thought process and what we need to do
is evaluate are we setting people up for
failure through the checks and balances
that we have in the system or are we
creating something that's really going
to Foster positive and forward thinking
I just would like to know one of the
questions to come out of this commission
if this committee is established is are
we still benefiting from the the
situations of incarcerated or formally
incarcerated people
I did my time I served it I made my
mistakes
do I still have to pay every day to
remain out here in the community should
be a question that I would like this
legislator to to consider I'm happy to
take any and all questions you may have
are you you're currently rap though are
you still paying uh supervisory fee no
I'm currently still on parole so I do
all supervisory fees until my parole is
ended and parole cannot be ended till
they're paid what is the uh is it the
same for everyone the fee or is it
different by person it's different from
person to person it's prorated according
to the salary that you make so the more
money you make the more your supervisor
fee is
um
sure uh representative Gathering thank
you Mr chair
how often is that paid
it's supposed to be but it's supposed to
be based on a monthly system
um it's it's based on a monthly system
but that's something that is set up
between the parolee and their parole
officer
the frequency of payments
so to your knowledge it's monthly to
your knowledge the Baseline is monthly
yes
and if it the the only things that I to
my knowledge would impact uh the
frequency of that to increase it would
be restitution I don't owe restitute I
don't know if you owe State restitution
or if you owed victim compensation or
things of that nature there could be um
or child support things of that nature
could impact the frequency but I don't
owe any child support I don't owe
restitution I didn't I don't own any
victim compensation it's solely
supervisory fees
where you provided an explanation as to
why one said one thing and one said
another
no
no I was not
no further questions thank you for your
testimony
we're all switching to testify in this
bill who has not done so
seeing none I will hereby close public
hearing on Senate Bill 251 and we are in
recess for the day